e
irregardless of what the Senate does
with us or the governor does with it um
we have a real mess with the budget in
terms of deficit and I think it's
important for the house to make a stand
on this and say whether and whether you
think cannabis is dangerous or you know
shouldn't be utilized it is being
utilized and people are going across the
borders to get it that's not going to
change and you know I think we need to
make a statement that this just m is
common sense and we need the
revenue uh I hear you but fortunately
the aspect of this bill is that the
first two years it's going to cost us 7
million and we won't get the revenue
until after the two years the revenue
well we'll still be in a mess so but so
basically you're actually making an
argument for why we don't want to pass
it now is because we don't have the the
room that's that's why it was such a
great committee room for me because
nobody we should go
under right right well let's this well
once once you know in terms of
subcommittees knowing that this room is
available it made perfect sense for
subcommittees but my light is on I'm
talking I'm
yeah I'm not I don't mind this is a
subcommittee we don't care right okay so
uh we were discussing uh what to do with
this
bill and um representative burrow was
saying how the how we need we need
revenue and this is clearly a revenue
making
Bill uh and I pointed out that that that
in the next the first couple of years of
it enactment it's it's a negative
Revenue
because you got to have spend all that
money to yeah to get it up and running
you know I mean
I someone was there a fiscal note on the
back of the bill and how much did it how
much how much does it
microphone um FY 2026 7,
94,000 I'm good huh am I not good that I
pull that $7 million number out of there
we
know7 is an even 8
million the the general fund
Appropriations
from that that yeah well that the
appropriation in terms of the actual you
know that that's the you know when it
says appropriation so
theoretically um and I assume this is an
early
Bill no fiscal note only means that they
sent Ed to some Department to do a
fiscal analysis it does not mean that
there's going to a second committee the
only chart the only chart that I
actually have the two charts that are
the secret secret charts that the secret
squirrel that tells you whether it goes
to another committee or not
unfortunately it doesn't tell you which
committee he's going to in this case
this is an early Bill let me see three
is this is three oh I'm looking the
wrong one uh question
186 yes this is an early
bill so we got to get this out question
we received an email with a a fiscal
note quick guide right and I don't see
there it doesn't say under appropriation
it says it on the here on the I don't
know does this replace what's in here or
is this an addition to what's
uh I don't know what's the date on
it doesn't have a date huh unless who
made who wrote it does
it didn't you see this no it was in your
email you know how many emails I
getday I don't know what to tell you I I
don't know if this replaces it or if
it's instead of or what's going on but
it doesn't have the 7even million so I'm
I'm recommending jar that we just main
the bill and that way we can see if our
fiscal
situation improves or not uh but at
least gives us some time to you know
figure out what's going to happen in
Senate and then have have them kill it
have it the Senate kill it and and then
and that means you can't have another
bill next
year cuz you've killed
the subject
matter so the Senate no no well I mean
we could pass another bill from the
house and then have the Senate kill it
again or actually the Senate would have
refused to take it it
just changes well you have to be
right I
think is a good bill I think this is the
bill that we lik the best from the last
session no we
don't I I'm I'm not agreeing with you on
that that I thought this was the best no
this bill was a was this bill was a
free-for-all this was this was this will
was allowed to it would allow to have
marijuana locations you know open up
okay and
so I think if I think if we know we know
what the environment is like I'm under
no
disillusion oh sweet let's go on board
the you need your mic on sorry yeah uh
Ian that's what the Senate does they've
killed a bunch of stuff that that we
have sent to them um I mean they're
responsible for for most marijuana bills
dying right so I mean but that doesn't
mean we don't send bills that we think
are good if we don't think it's good
then we should use as working session to
try to make it better if if you really
do have issues with it but by and large
I think the house position should be we
think marijuana should be legalized
we've had that position
[Music]
for since before I've been here we've
passed a lot of things prior to that and
that's what the people of New Hampshire
want and if if the Senate and the
governor want to be responsible for not
passing and not becoming legal in this
state then that's on them but we don't
we aren't going to we shouldn't be
driven by what the governor or what the
Senate wants specifically the Senate I
mean we're we're two bodies we we get to
we get to decide what's best if they
think nothing is best and they're just
not going to take it up then that's on
them they can they can be accountable to
the voters but we should do what the
voters want and and we always have and I
don't think we should be dictated by
them so that's my stance I don't think
we should retain it well the reason I
recommend retaining is that we it's it's
another year that's closer to
election so then it's going to be much
more in the hearts and minds of you know
when it gets to the Senate will be you
know uh in you know close to the signing
up season next year MH so at least the
Senators will be be more higher profile
if they vote to they've been pretty
clear to me already privately and
somewhat publicly that they're not going
to take up anything that that I
understand that but I'm saying that's
but I'm saying so there all the more
reason not to send them a bill I mean I
I I you you want to send the message oh
yeah we we're agree and want to do that
but I'm saying is is that now you want
to be somewhat strategic about it in
terms of when when do we want to have
have the state conversation and debate
and argument over over the bill wouldn't
it be better to do it in the second year
when it's closer to election rather than
the first year uh which is right now
it's it's all come come by a and we all
want to you know get the you know the
first year everybody's going to you know
it's all about the budget and and and to
pass a bill that's going to cost $7
million I mean they'll they'll just kill
it on that issue representative walls
thank you Mr chair excuse
me I just wanted to point out that um
not everyone in the house is for this
bill we now have toen opposition in the
room at the moment yes and I will
continue to oppose this vehemently um
and I not to speak for the governor but
I believe the governor is against it
because she supports law enforcement and
excuse me again most of law enforcement
Community is against this um however I
did have a question regarding this
particular bill was there always
a cannabis commission that's um
page8 line
17 was that was that always part of the
original so actually the original
original issues always had a cannabis
commissions but that when we in 23 my my
thumb print was to throw it under the
Liquor Commission that we didn't want to
create a new commission that one
commission was good enough now it turns
out I not that I'm a rocket scientist
but if you watch what happened to the
marijuana Commission in
Massachusetts it's a
scandal every every
week another scandal's coming out so so
it's almost you know that again the idea
was that it would be far more efficient
economically if we just kept it within
one commission the state of Washington
did that they actually changed the name
of their liquor and add cannabis to its
title yes followup so so this bill as
opposed to the ones previously which
were in League with or controlled by the
Liquor Commission would wants to
establish its own separate commission is
that what I'm hearing okay correct yeah
so my thinking on that was and from
talking with a lot of the various
Advocates on this topic is is while we
have
and it this isn't this certainly isn't a
hill I would die on if somebody wants to
change this we can change this but the
thinking is is liquor and cannabis are
different they're regulated substances
but they are different and so the way
the business Works would be different
it's not going to be regulated
necessarily the same and so uh because
of that
that a a a separate commission with with
experts that have knowledge on the
cannabis industry versus uh just
assuming that the liquid commission
could step right in and and not have to
be brought up to speed they'd still have
to hire some sort of experts um and so I
guess it's it's in at some level
semantics if if the liquid commission is
going to be in charge of it they still
have to hire these sorts of experts who
actually understand the the space in a
way that they don't now because they
don't have any experience in it um and
so I just figured keep it separately
that that that would probably to me make
more sense but uh again not a hill I
would die on yeah because it's creating
bigger
government well I mean I would have to
say where where I I agree with you that
yes the bill will require um some
expertise in terms of the C you know
terms of the
oversight however the key element of the
Liquor Commission is the enforcement of
the sale to underage people MH okay and
say and sail to a person who's uh is
indulged right you're not supposed to be
stoned when you go buy marijuana just
like we you you know if you're too drunk
you're not going to have alcohol so the
issue was that are you going to hire a
whole new enforcement division to
enforce that element that's where the
Liquor Commission was really where's the
cost saving um and not just you know the
thing um not just the the issue of you
know dealing with the intricacies of the
Cannabis and and and the problems of of
why cannabis is different than alcohol
and number one issue with what I've been
reading is the um
mold the Cannabis is has mold and and
they're and then some states are really
laxed about the testing California
evidently is very laxed about the
testing and and they're finding mold all
over the place and uh so
whereas so yes there are some elements
in which you're going to have to have
special specialist when it comes to
Canon but in terms of the actual
enforcing the uh no sale under
21 we we have a division for it and
actually this actually is going to come
up with the uh the bill that got is now
being withdrawn it's officially being
withdrawn and I basically I talked her
into withdrawing it because this is
about selling uh exercise U whatever the
uh what's the term the bill
um supplements right there were sub the
supplements and get down to she she was
saying well we passed it in New York and
I said so who's your enforcement agency
she said the Attorney General's office
and I go well our attorney general's
office is is interested only in our
Consumer Protection Law is only is only
restitution you know get your get your
money back okay not to enforce 21y old
21y old 18year old age so that was what
really who really enforces it so
representa
spear over the past two years and then
this year we've heard a lot from The
Liquor Commission and when I first
started out I didn't really know who
they were or what they were but I've
gained a lot of respect for them and I
really appreciate the job that they do
and how well they do it and understand
what they're doing so the idea that we
put this under the Liquor Commission I I
I really think that's a good idea I
don't have a problem problem with
that the um some of the limitations that
we had in that last bill from the end of
last year was pretty Grim so that
doesn't have to be the same way but I
think that it under the Liquor
Commission I think it's the right thing
to
do representative Burrows I I think the
the house again it's a different house
because the election but I think the
house last time was pretty clear that it
did not want the Liquor Commission to
oversee this no it was the it was the it
wasn't so much The Liquor Commission it
was the way that they had so many of
this and so many the LI the licenses was
limited to 16 I think it was more
personally I think I think there's was
may you may feel a mistake but I I
definitely think uh they people did not
want the leg commission overseeing it so
they were really thought it was a good
idea to go out and hire new
enforcers they not no but they didn't
know that issue that that's that's an
ins I think I I think the part that they
were concerned about is is the $8
million was going into the Liquor
Commission to right I think that's what
it was $8 million if I recall that was
going to expand their enforcement thing
and a lot of people were uncomfortable
with that
um I mean I I this is not me my position
what I'm about to say but right
um a lot of people don't like the Liquor
Commission like whether that's fair or
not is a different point I'm just
telling I get a lot of feedback and
through that proc process when I took my
stance I I wasn't specifically fighting
against the Liquor Commission part of it
like I said that's not the hill I'm
going to die on I was far more concerned
about the licensing numbers but I I was
not I I was surprised at how many people
were very upset about the Liquor
Commission part of it and and I did say
that in one of my speeches that we're
going to be expanding this this
unelected
bureaucracy um by giving them $8 million
initially um that was one of the spe was
one of the lines I said in my one of my
speak did you get the impression that
people understood what the Liquor
Commission does no it's it's like it's
anything you know it's big government
and people you know me let alone the
bill you know the whole about restaurant
you know getting getting rid of the
liquor enforcement you know getting the
food the checking the food the whole
food requirements I mean all of this
people I mean let's face it it's a
Byzantine loss right it's it's a mother
mayi it's like zoning and and it's
people hate that you know that you can't
do anything without getting the bless
from from The Liquor Commission and
people are offended by that I I can
understand why people are I mean I've
I've heard it over the years that people
have issues with li what was the um
marijuana uh limit on Edibles what's in
what's in your bill I was trying to look
for it I couldn't find it the limit like
the THC yeah I don't know I don't recall
if I had that some reason I thought I
saw
is
um so it is 10
then so is this going to be like Maine
where you're selling plants and seeds
and selling every anything and
everything
um I don't think it's specifically cover
selling
plants um I think C seeds are
not I think the seeds are fine I think
Joe have you read the whole thing
through
regulated right because they're not
Caesar you
can right you just don't know where they
come from but
is all our
people money and it's predicted that we
this
right
potential M on this way
high7 12 billion budget
every that's that's not a lot of money
to make tens of
forcades and you studied it you looked
at it Theiss was one the IDE first study
commission back uh that was when nobody
thought that their commission need to be
involved when they testified I
specifically asked them you know so I
said you do a great job you raise tons
of money for the state you sell you know
as much alcohol as you possibly can and
so if we want to sell as much marijuana
as possible charge they like you know
it's a business they're trying to sell
their usage down that's not happen in
the side of every Highway and people are
worried about being everywhere being too
strong you can buy brain alcohol the
side of almost every Highway in the
state yeah oh yeah so you know as far as
regulation
and
en the number one thing they're doing is
keep do even we have 20 or 30 stores
first few years how many people you need
to enforce 20 stores to just check
out you need million
issues yeah but this this how many
stores that Maine have Maine's got like
do
that
enfor that's such a small
and and I think it's important to say uh
we just heard Maine I I don't want this
bill to be like tied in with Maine
because Maine is a really not a good
example like it's you know it's been
referred to by some of the people that
I've spoken to uh through the through
just process and like you know the
advocates for this as sort of the Wild
Wild West this is this is more similar
to like Vermont's bill um Main's bill is
particularly when you have like the
medical side like it's anybody can get a
license there's like no regulations on
it so those stores pop up people get
them confused um you
know as far as like they being an
enormous number of stores it's going to
take a while for that to happen because
no I just I found it here on page 35
anybody anybody can get a store yeah
anybody can be selling be have a have a
gas station and sell cannabis you can
you can sell yes so let me so this is
this is now if we're going to take that
number we know that right now when it
comes to who sells cigarettes in okay no
so it you anybody can have a store it's
not going to be gas station it's not a
dedicated store to cannabis the way this
is written is it well unless it's
somewhere else to say it has to be a
dedicated
store but I'm on page 35 they're shall
engage in serving taxable meals rented
rooms and renting Motor Vehicles or
license you so you C you there'll be one
one Li uh no more than three licenses
per
person okay so where's
that I don't know where all the pages
are I just know the language
right well here here's the reason why
I'm suggesting we retain the bill is
that theoretically just like the
marijuana
commission it goes through the
bill entirety and talks about every
element of the bill okay we don't have
time to do that right now right I mean
we could do this right this morning we
can try to do through it okay but we
have to have this bill out it it's an
early Bill okay so um we we have to have
it out by the six so I'm just saying is
is that it seems to me it makes more
sense to wait till come September and
then really go through the bill
paragraph by paragraph and decide you
know whether you know what the bill is
trying to do and what's to do so that we
all can speak you know intelligently
about what's in this
bill but if you want to just steamroll
it through you know it's fine but I I I
would guess I just the issue of having
this commission and have a separate
commission I mean that that's a killer
for me mean I I I I've always I was on
the position that it was that I wanted
to give it to the Liquor Commission
right from the Geto but yeah Ron spear
if we have to have a commission anyway
I'm not clear on why that
commission is looked at in any way more
favorably what what commission oh excuse
me the the marijana commission that's in
here oh this Liquor Commission right
then the Liquor Commission would be okay
still this is a misnomer of that word
commission okay so what what this let's
call um the so-called commission that we
had that Jaren and I were both on that
was a chapter study that was a no no I'm
not talking about that the liquor study
committee I'm not talking about that
okay all right what I'm talking about is
this thing sets up a cannabis commission
correct versus The Liquor Commission
correct they're both government entities
correct that both going to have rules so
why would the Liquor Commission if we if
it's spun the right way be looked at any
more unfavorably than another commission
that we have but but this bill
specifically States they're creating a
new com marijuana commission why is
there an advantage to that I'm opposed
to it the argument would be that the
argument would be that that it would be
a dedicated thing focusing on this
unique industry it's a new industry and
if I think the reason why people are
conflating liquor and cannabis is
because they're both regulated
substances and so we think it's just oh
we're just regulating a regulated
substance and the idea is that well
there's still differences so if you're
going to have to hire people who have
expertise on all that stuff why can't we
just have one focus on it like why do we
but there's an infrastructure involved
and can and the Liquor Commission
handles tobacco without any problem and
that's a different substance alog
together yeah but this this this is this
is separate because there could to be
testing of the the purity of stuff all
that sort of stuff and so well they
don't do the testing they require you to
send it out to a testing entity but
there all regulations they have to
regulate that tester to mean to make
sure that test testing entity is is
competent right so they have to regulate
all that so that's the idea of just
having them be able to focus on that
it's like anything when government
agencies get large
they become less effective right and so
making one agency bigger and bigger are
they going well first of all I don't
necessarily agree that that's the case
but they have the infrastructure and
know how to do the job but do they they
don't have they don't have any
experience with cannabis so I don't but
neither does anybody else right now and
regulate it and get in the state but but
certainly they they do have some people
who do right like they have the atcs
that already in existence right and
there's there's some Frameworks around
that so the people who are already have
some of their hands in the pot can come
in and help you know maybe be hired to
do something that's the thinking again
I'm not going to die in this hill this
is not that important to me but the idea
that like Liquor Commission is some sort
of like oh they got this figured out I
think is also a bit of a
misnomer that's my argument I'm not
going to die in this hill don't care
that much about it but you have an
opinion yeah this is a subcommittee so
separate
separate by the
way members and think
expert so there are many experts in the
field would be on The Advisory Board be
invting the small commission they'll be
more efficient U but if they have to
worry about enforcement they can
cooperate with any other state local
agency do any of that stuff commission
wanted to be contracted just brought in
for enforcement for each
easily but also the advisory board's a
little bit different than the commission
too
so bu
reses
bu there are
experience they just have to do the
business
states I don't see a place for uh new
Futures on there so she'll be demanding
a
seat on the commission it'll be on the
advisory
committee board sh okay this is theard
so where's the advisory committee yes
exactly H would be I'm looking at page
11 which is that must be the commission
itself no this is the advis
that's advisor right so I am looking the
right place yes I think she going be
looking for a seat she's going to be
looking for a seat she' be
under two experts in public health or
something
yeah same with
what
oh yeah yeah this is free it's a freefor
all
so what I was going to say is that um I
think one of the concerns with the
Liquor Commission was that they were
going to um give some of the big
businesses an edge up and getting
licenses because they were limited
licenses yeah and they were already I
mean you could see some of the
developers in New Hampshire and Beyond
already Belling up to the bar right to
get in right that was the that was the
heal that there was limited licenses and
that it was a it was think it was
Howard Howard said this is just going to
be a rich man sport yeah exactly yeah
that's why this wouldn't allow that and
I think that's why the house defeated
that version I think that was the for me
that was why but I think that's why it
was defeated yeah the limited licenses
what was they didn't like the LI
commission a lot of people didn't like
the LI commission the reason I took such
a Firm Stance was the the fixed license
yeah limited number limited
John
okay yeah I I guess I just I you know
for for me I I would I would really need
bill mean why do we have all these
different license we have on page 13 we
have the annual licensing
fee adjusted inflation depending based
on the consumer product manufactur that
are not authorized to per bable
extraction is 10,000 for retail cannabis
store and cannabis product so they're
feed authorized to perform well all
extractions what is this what does this
all mean vol what is a volatile
extraction
volatile for tier okay so 250 for a tier
one cannabis cultivator
facility is it is this like a Nano Nano
cultivator yeah something small
basically yeah that's how you could
yeah this is okay just so you know the
Liquor Commission has yes it has a fair
amount of fees but every fee is related
to the nature of the underlying business
so in other words yes we have a pull P
pool room business so you have to have
10 pool tables okay we have a tennis
court license you got to have two tennis
courts so in terms of it's the the the
nature of the underlying provider not
the you know terms of the volume or you
know we actually the the one interesting
the volume difference is we actually uh
uh hurt we we make the volume sales you
know you always say the more volume you
buy the cheaper the price you should get
it at well not in New Hampshire what
comes the liquor because when it comes
to buying wine wine the grocery stores
have to pay more for the wine to put the
wine on their shelves than the small Mom
Mom and Pop convenience store and it's
it's a million dollar threshold so if
you have a certain if you do more than a
million dollars worth of sale then then
down exactly
exactly it was
yep do we think do we think it's going
to be problematic that there are no
Republicans who are on this bill that's
only because the system failed not
because they don't okay it might have
been that way but they're not on here so
I just I'm asking whether it's going to
be problematic I think so I I would hope
not I mean Erica Leon is on board she
told me to put her on it and then like
you were supposed to be on it as well
yeah I never saw it it just this this OS
system just was screwed up do you I mean
do you know I mean are there other I
mean I love working with Erica I mean
are there people other people who you
think would be on board and working with
Erica on the other on the other side of
the
aisle uh yeah I yeah I think so I mean I
I I think by and large there are certain
I mean that that party is more divided
right you guys are more divided so
there's the people who are very against
it and there's the more pre-at
Libertarians who are more Pro Pro it so
I think that that split isn't going to
sponsorship yeah it's a this is sub
commmittee it's a free-for all it's a
free-for all thank you it's a freefor
all um so I I know um last
term um a person representative who has
been trying to get cannabis passed but
doesn't like um the liquor commission or
anyone I mean they they just want to
grow do their thing not be regulated and
not be regulated and we've we've put
that through again and again but if
there's some way we can bring those
people in and you know try to get them
to support this or you know I can try to
reach out to some of these people to
maybe get on and have a conversation and
um try to do something about it I mean
I'm not I'm not trying to exclude
anybody uh literally this the system was
messed up that's the only reason just me
and Heath ended up on it I was supposed
to Anita uh dick Faxton he wanted to be
on it um Eric Leon like so there was a
bunch of people who wanted to be on it
and when I put them in just
happened whatever reason I don't know
what happened in the system apparently
it happened to other people too it
wasn't me I thought it was user error
but other people told me they had the
same problem so so I I I think if they
are interested
they get yeah yeah they can talk but
they can get up I mean I put in bills
that you know were one and pasted I was
um I we just have to reach out to those
people I think now and say Hey you know
are you supporting this and maybe have
everybody look at it in case they
haven't and um kind of if we need to
parse some things out sure yeah I'm fine
with
that well that's not my
nature my nature is is to go through it
and and make sure everything in it makes
sense but to just pass it and say okay
we'll if anybody has a problem you got
two years you got two years to fix it
because nothing is going to happen
actually I'm seen here it looks like
well that was your argument last time
right we going to have time to fix it a
knowledge was bad it I acknowledged that
yeah but but I also spent a lot of time
going through the bill paragraph by
paragraph right that's that's a famous
Pelosi quote we have to pass it so that
we can read it to see what's in
it no I mean people aren't I mean it's
it's a little frustrating that we're not
in a position to like do that now just
because of a short deadline or whatever
but um um well that's why I'm saying we
should retain it and then really do that
work how much time do we actually
have how much time we actually have to
go through this bill yeah okay well
um
we uh are you going to go away on the
vacation okay so you you we do have that
week you could spend the whole week
working on going through the bill not me
I'm just saying
but I will not be
around I will not be around so but in
terms of
myself uh why am I keep when's the data
has to be out by uh technically it has
to be out March
6 so that I was planning to schedule all
these
bills um for March Tuesday March 4th if
I can find a
room if I can't find a room then we're
down to March I I could and maybe we
could do rep's hall or something and I
can you know try to do something and and
and I'd
get Paul to let me do it given that he
he wants to make sure all the blur
because the blurbs have got to get in
really quickly the the final day the
actual day is technically March 6 but
they've scheduled a session for March
6 doesn't make any sense to me but
that's what they did so um I could I we
could just say we're going to EXA
everything uh Wednesday
morning March
you that has it has to be if you're
going deliv we would have an amendment
and we would at that point we would be
voting on The the amend amended Bill and
and then recommend do you think that's
feasible Jared I mean from your
perspective worse for me if if if we
want to do it I'm not the one I'm not
the one who's going to be gone so I I
can I can make whatever work I mean do
you feel like you could pull together I
mean not just people I don't know what
the complaints are so yeah I I mean I'm
fine with the bill pretty much as is
nobody it seems like people just aren't
prepared to talk about this bill at this
time so if we just need time for people
to read through the bill and have some
more questions if I
mean that's what I'm saying I'm a little
frustrated just because we have we well
we're not in here talking about what we
don't like or how to make things better
it seems like we just aren't ready to
talk about this bill yet and that's fine
um then what we need to probably do is
have another session I don't know next
week or something if we're going to do
this to to just actually dig into it and
have people read through it yeah okay so
let's I'll get right to the point and I
it does this
bill allow any
convenience store to sell
marijuana that no I don't think so okay
so you'd have to have a you has to be a
standalone
location okay can you tell me where that
is I don't know and and that's certainly
not the intent but I can double check
the language I'd have to dig through it
right I'll put that question down and I
can review
that so you're you seem to be afraid of
like 7-Eleven getting a we it's going
well right now like the big complaints
is these you know gas station um they
selling beer wine
cigarettes they used to sell pornography
but I guess they don't do that anymore
because everybody gets get get on the
internet but but um but it was you know
was those kind of fly by night you know
beer wine tobacco
places in all fairness to the sponsors
and the issue that
we to go through this again and come
back and see if we can make tweaks with
anything that we're not comfortable with
and move forward this it's gone on for
decades and decades yeah why you know I
just right and and I don't feel bad that
I won't be there because um at this
moment as long as you're insisting that
you're going to keep it under you know
create this new commission then I I I
can't I can't get behind this at all I'm
not insistent I didn't say that I was
okay well then that you would when you
it's up to you but at this point that I
mean to my to my thinking the number one
problem I have is in terms of my number
one complaint is this uh creating a new
commission that commission I want the El
commission to oversee it yeah um and
um and then in terms of um assuming that
everything everything else has the
proper testing and the you know controls
mean I I I know that the only other
issue that the committee got bogged down
on which was the uh legalization and the
decriminalization and it looks like
that's in this bill right yeah right
right this yeah that's in here it's also
another bill which I don't know if it's
how it's going to come out of the
Justice committee but right that same
language there and then it's in here as
so um yeah so if you if you rewrite the
bill and and get rid of that commission
then I can get behind I'll I'll be
supportive of the bill otherwise I'm I I
bill personally but like I say I'm going
to be I'm going to be gone you know may
next week next week we got to um we have
uh we got a
we got to get start we got to exact we
got to get exact all these all the bills
I want to do and then I we still have I
what I have left we have so we have 13
early
bills that have to be done by by let's
say let's call it March 5th we'll have
to be done March 5th that I was kind of
hoping to get some done next
week and then we haven't
heard
um 11 bills we have 11 bills we still we
haven't even heard yet and they have to
20th that's the remaining 11 bill that's
the remaining all the bills that we
haven't even heard yet let alone whether
we've done the subcommittees and really
know what we're doing with them all so
to me working this bill is a the huge
time consumer and and could take a lot
of lot of work um and we just don't
really have the time for it and that's
why I'm I'm suggesting that you we
retain it and then work on it in
September and and um and in that case we
have all the time in the world to to get
it done done
right I'd rather do it now I
mean the fall is my time to try to make
money and I get sucked into the last
commission that I was on and what do you
mean sucked in you missed as many as I
did
because I had to start working it's hard
for me to do the work of this job
effectively we don't get paid we all
know that right and I have to make money
somehow and I try to do as much working
as I can in the fall right last fall I
worked six jobs including this
and and so I would rather have my Falls
you rather just get sing start push it
through and have it have it di it's
going to die I know it's going to die
I'm under No Illusion that we're going
to pass this I've known that since the
election results but okay that's not on
me that's on the people who choose not
to pass it and that's just one johned to
it you know the political
environment I think that is completely
no they're not going to suddenly like oh
it's an election year we now have seen
the
light
well there's a big stretch there for a
lot of
so I'm just going to
uh yeah I I I think I think we should
just pass it and and
if we can pass it we can try to come
back if when they kill it in the senate
or if by some miracle it makes it to the
governor's des and she vetos
it then we can debate whether or not to
do something next year but like this
bill's here now let's get it done now um
if there's concerns with respect to the
Liquor Commission I can certainly work
on that language to appease John's
concerns um I will confirm that this
nothing my vote is that important you
know you don't have to if you if you
believe that that you're consist people
but I would like you to support it
you're like an important person to
support this but I'm only one person
you're you you got to get oh
2011 chairman question if if we
did if we did you know move it over to
the commission and Jared doesn't seem to
be too and you could get on board with
this do you still see it not having any
chance in the Senate oh the bill is dead
I agree with that the bill is dead in
any case I haveed this a long time ago
that's why I don't that's why I think we
need to startop even talking about that
like who cares what they say you're just
giving me a reason to vote no it's you
know okay having the commission but to
having to put the to put the Commission
in yes that that least that'll get me to
vote yes on the house side but in the
end of the day the odds of this ever
going seen the light of day in the
think that's right we were the first St
great the highest number has always been
a model this done it before was majority
real close in fact the Democrats in my
County would
majority throwing that out blaming on
all Democrats obviously many Republicans
didn't sign on but it's passed time and
time again and we've studied it at nause
if people don't like it that's you know
one or two things about it that's right
so my vote doesn't matter right you
this no but the state model originally
pass
us no no no you're confused using with
when it came back from the Senate but
when we sent the original bill over he's
not talking about he was talking about
it some other time
okay and know what we got stuck with we
were told the only sign by the governor
that wer that well that's where that's
what yeah what I'm saying what gets
goofy here is is that the the house was
okay when we passed with the Liquor
Commission with the control with the
limited amount of stores they were okay
with that they voted it and was I think
it was pretty close to being veto proof
at with the vote but then when it got
over to the Senate and the Senate
started adding back in all the things
that they wanted okay then at that point
the house members you know it lost by
four votes I mean they basically deleted
our language and put a new bill they
didn't delete that but the majority of
only that I did say that and so they
voted no and therefore then then it
no that just proves proves me right that
pastes my constituents that call me
email me whatever they they with the
cost of living these days they don't
want an income tax but they want pot so
that we'll have enough money right in
the state so I get a lot of that from
people um and I think this is kind of a
year that maybe we do get a little
momentum on that just my thoughts I've
had absolutely the opposite I have had
no one in my town and in surrounding
towns when I go visit that wants this
that wants
cannabis most of the people that contact
[Laughter]
it no no we have the
there
there social media and just they
actually smoke on a video or online
nobody really cares that level you know
there might be individuals who don't
want it but they don't have to smoke if
I feel like there's a what what is that
saying if if you want to if you want to
you want if you want to see if a a law
is bad enforce it strictly because then
you'll have people riots if they enforce
this strictly like at the federal level
this would become legal real quick
because people would be in uprag because
so many people would be in jail so many
people would be arrested we were just
talking about smoking in restaurants and
yet Parts smell and stench I
everywhere you can't no that's but we've
don't go there because that is the one
big issue people have is they say look
at the states that passed it right you
cannot go you can't go anywhere in
Colorado you can't go to what is that
red rock concert without you know you
you Red Rock you're going to be stoned
when you leave because everybody's
question I I would have to say i' have
to say I'm old enough to say that yes I
went to plenty of concerts that I didn't
mean they all the monkeys see Stone
monkeys I mean I I guess I guess the
question I went to Bruce Spring scen
concerts that people weren't smoking
pots the question is just enforcement do
we want to enforce it like it's it is
outlawed it's outlawed to smoke
cigarettes and in certain parks and
stuff too
um but people still do it so exactly but
those are enforc what's that smoking in
in you know like in Ry Beach that that
is enforced where right yeah so like
that so this could be enforced too is
what I'm saying yeah I mean whether or
not it gets enforced or not problem is
is the this law can't be enforced on its
own like we have to actually have people
have a will to do it and you
know well the libertarian me says you
know what let's just make it legal and
call it a day let people grow their own
I fine with home grow I would rather I
would I I would rather have people just
grow their own rather than having it
having people buy it because then then
because then you don't set up the
bureaucracy about you know the mold and
you don't have to set up in whatever
what people do the quality and do all
that that model John where's the
bill I I I I thought there was a bill
was that wasn't there a bill that that
just yes yes I think it's important to
is anybody do
it know he killed he killed our bill
last yeah he was against it he was
against the one last time the same one
that I was against not not against the
first one
right I think it's important that we
that we uh limit the smoking in public
and and I say that only be and this does
so the idea of just letting everybody
have a free roll it has five times the
tar of a cigarette and for people who
have heart disease that's bad so I'm
thinking that we have to not let this go
and have a free-for all we have to have
be enforced but it already is it's
illegal in the state now and you could
smell marijuana everywhere
so yeah and I just think I just think I
think this is one of the thing like I
don't care and I'm just kind of pointing
out the reality of the way the world
works from my perspective anyways is I
think it's funny that we get all caught
up on public smoking people are public
smoking now it's illegal in the state
and people are publicly smoking now so I
just think it's funny that like like
language matter no it is not publicly
it's it's it's illegal in restaurants
but you can stand on the side talking
about marijuana marijuana is legal
across the whole state and yet I I smell
people smoking it all the time like it's
just it's it's I think there's to to
your point everybody who wants to smoke
in the state is either going to Vermont
Maine or Massachusetts and buying it and
consuming it and then smoking it
publicly in New Hampshire and so it's
already illegal it's either it's already
those laws are not being enforced enough
that not smelling
it excuse me well I would have to say in
the defense of this this our current
situation is that um the people who are
smoking there are some okay but they're
very subtle about it they have you know
in terms of these little one hitter
things and they're trying to you know
trying to minimize people to smell it
and um and are certainly conscious of
not doing it in you know large public
places where a lot of people are and
which law enforcement standing right
there there MH okay so but
yes no matter what you do it's you're
never going to truly you know it's just
enforcement that but so that one of the
arguments for those who are opposed to
marijuana is that is that um the amount
of marijuana they smell now is going to
be a lot it's a lot less than once you
legalize it then even though you have
the statue and said you got the you got
the $100 penalty you know for the first
offense um it it it people become more
um arrogant about about not worrying
about getting and I not like I don't
really care funny thing is I don't even
consume marijuana so none of this really
matters me I just think we should stop
arresting people for it but the uh but
we just agree that nobody's getting
arrested now that's not true though like
they the New Hampshire's own data shows
that people get arrested every
year yeah yeah but no but right now law
enforcement the only time law
enforcement enforces it is when they
pull you over for speeding and the car
you know be open the door and and the
pillow smoke comes the the numbers show
that there are people still
being and um but I'm getting like like
people are like trolling me on on
Twitter for for this whole public
smoking thing I'm just like wow like
there's just no way to get everybody
happy so right that is
true so this is up to you what you want
to do you know with the bill I can make
these changes I'm recommend retaining it
if you guys don't want to retain it then
you I'd like to not retain it you can uh
you can uh go ahead and and schedule
I'll I'll put you in charge of the of
the subcommittee and you can call the
subcommittee meetings and you can do
whatever you guys want to do and and do
whatever you want to do and and see
whatever you can you can come back with
and and we'll we'll look for uh right
now we're time out
March March 5th assuming that I still
can't find a committee room for March
4th
but it sounds like all the other
committees why are the Committees so
hard to find this year um well I would
have to say that I know exactly why
because we had labor the labor in uh
fishing game committee room on Tuesdays
last
year but that committee doesn't that
right and then they added an extra
committee so in
well right you know theoretically it
should you know maybe get a little
better you know we move out but but at
the end of the day it's very annoying
Thursdays I could come how to bring the
committee act after session I can bring
the committee back but that that is not
idea sure yeah yeah I think we should
work on it and get it done and then not
the I can reach out to them and if
people have names right you have have
you can do whatever you want to do to
get you know but basically basically
we're going to you know um I would
recommend that you make sure whatever
you have that amendment is done by the
fourth and get it out to everybody you
know because you know if you're going to
throw a 36 page bill in front of me 38
40 page bill in front of me that I've
never seen I I I need a little chy to
but I would still argue that retaining
is the right
answer I'd say we should work on it and
sure we v on it on March or whatever day
comes after at that point folks don't
feel like we've got something worthwhile
that we can retain it well if when we
when when we have our EXA
session right we can to certainly go
around the conversation and see where
people are and then and basically the
choice would be uh to to either vote for
the
amendment or or vote vote to keep the
bill as in its current form or retain it
and that that options be open I'm just
telling you that I cannot vote for this
bill in its current
form and I
so all right so um for your note well
you got lots of notes on this one yeah
mess okay so we're gonna make a motion
or uh no we're going at this point uh
we're um
uh that we will have another
out and we'll but it it we will vote on
it come March 5th and I'm going to do
and I'm saying March 5th in the morning
rather than in the afternoon so if
you're going to try to solve things you
could have this
room
probably um on on March
4th I'll go lock it down
now yeah I'll talk to Robin to lock it
down now so that you can have this room
for that for March
4th that is a
Tuesday and then Wednesday morning we
got to exact and then we got to have we
got to exact the 13 early bills
that's that's the main bogey here and
you have the whole vacation week you
have all the time in the world to figure
it
outar on the
fine that would be a subcommittee that
right that clock I got it to work for a
little bit and then it died again I
think it's just the batter's low I think
it's needs a new it needs a new batter
no exactly it got it got to 10:30 and
then he died
okay all right so the next one is
relocating positions in The Liquor
Commission your bill yes I obviously
think you're for it yeah I don't think
there was any problems with the
relocation everybody was okay with that
I'm surprised they're not
here but I hate to hope I hope they're
not thinking they're upstairs but sorry
what bill number was this
538 even Joe testified I think I wasn't
here so Joe as in m yes there he is
oh so they were they didn't want to come
tape okay so um anybody have any
problems with these changes in positions
and refinement and did we save money
with it with this or was it just really
yeah you stay in in in compliance with
the
uh
right
right right yeah it seemed a little
weird that it was an early bill but it
might go to Edna rather than Finance but
I don't know assuming you know it's
position it's a position so I'm sure
it's going to go to
finance so okay
committee okay all
right so pusk Burrows wals Sullivan Post
Spear and
second oh the question
clear all those in favor say I I those
unanimous uh one two three four five six
zip it's for somebody who used to work
okay so the only other um
[Music]
we consider our actions on the
restaurant oh yeah
restaurant and drawing up an amendment
that will create a Tavern
license and give a town to your town to
en
Ena
anxious so also
uhing we have another
[Music]
the the bar bar bus or whatever you want
to call it om the Omnibus Bill of bars
out the late night openings and stuff
no now this one is did that one come
having call it social
[Music]
that it but that the issue was that
there are two
[Music]
what they did was we we had
of well you're
smoke
jar
yeah this bill goes is now go and wait
evid
without
too
e
yeah uh I'll tell you specifically what
here so in the original Bill there were
some definitions around stable coin
staking staking as a service those are
all removed they're not relevant with
these
changes uh Roman numeral
2 there was a reference to stable coins
it said end stable coins from the
general fund so that's that's been uh
stricken from the
bill in the old version there was a
Roman numeral 5 that said the state
treasur may engage in lending or staking
of qualified digital assets that's been
removed so we we took all those
references
out and then the
main the main change to the substance of
the
bill Roman numeral 3 it used to say not
invest more than 10% so we cut that down
and so we had a a zoom meeting with the
state treasurer representative Spears
representative M and myself and we went
over uh represent of Spears had a
question about should the general fund
be taken out and the treasure seemed to
indicate that that's okay to leave in
yeah and
and my my general sense was she's not
looking to urgently utilize this but
would like to have it at in the
toolbox and and she seemed you know open
to that that was my impression
so yeah the other impression that I got
also was that this is an enabling kind
of thing she's going to do what she has
to do yeah right and so it isn't like
we're forcing anybody to do anything it
just gives her a little more ammunition
to work with which she may not do right
away
my my comment was that again this is
totally inappropriate for many of things
she does this is not short-term money
this is really long-term money a place
for it might be in the state pension
plan for example um I don't know that we
specifically mention that in here
Keith no I would be up to their discuss
yeah but so I mean nobody's going to go
out and buy a bunch of Bitcoin in the uh
in the payroll fund for sure yeah she
said she she and her board of directors
are going to make those decisions we're
not going to we're not forcing her to
make any decisions she and her board of
directors make those decisions as to
goes I just
got well I just have a c question for
Keith so so Keith actually uh Anita and
I were just talking about she mentioned
stable fund and I said that f yeah
stable coin I said that's not exactly
what president Trump is talking about
he's talking about basically having uh
putting somewh of a safety net among
crypto um that scares the hell out of me
I don't know what you mean St safety
net um are we talking about this bill
anymore well I just it it's relation to
crypto and I want to make sure that
we're not going in that direction that
in other words he would you know for
example uh you go on you buy a CD you've
got uh FDIC coverage we have no coverage
on stocks we have no coverage on bonds
but from what I understand he's talking
about some sort of a a backup a dollar
backup to bitcoin which I think is crazy
I I don't I haven't heard that okay
information what I what I have heard is
there's a there's a commission there's a
new
cryptar uh in the entire Administration
is pretty much crypto-friendly from top
to bottom it's a a whole it is a radical
sea change that's just happen and the
commission is tasked with their first
their first uh task from the president
is to look into creating a reserve a
strategic reserve of Bitcoin and
potentially other digital assets that's
not going to necessarily back up the
dollar it would just
be uh the the US government having a
stake in you know that that scarce
resource right that that's fine but not
that's not the way I sort of interpret
it that's why I was asking
you there is separate there is separate
stable coin legislation from the federal
level and that's it's really a dollar
backed digital token it's one you know
it's pegged to the the value of the
dollar and that's that's sort of stable
token I think the federal government
already has about 15 billion in Bitcoin
already 200,000 200
um they They seized 200,000 from various
Bad actors and they have at least
200,000 oh I I was looking the other day
and I think they've got closer to 15
billion they did sell off some yeah they
have 19 billion 19 billion so okay
they're on their way to making a reserve
so but that's not this bill so that's
not this bill the stable
token was part of this bill and and that
would be like as transactions move to
stable tokens you can take your stable
tokens and you can stake them sort of
like interest bearing we talked about
staking before and there there whole
there's a whole industry built growing
up around that I don't think it's
probably too far down the path for this
there's nothing else to say the
treasurer seemed to think it was okay we
it got paired down to what we all agreed
to we chatted for I don't know half an
hour maybe longer what if there's a
different doesn't make any difference
they have a board of directors they have
to answer to and they have to keep us
certain they all get fired like they did
in
DC this is not a mandate to to buy
anything no I understand I understand
yeah it's just enabling okay no I just
worried about it'll be a cold day in
Hell before she actually I know she's
not going to be she won't be around if
they win
the look this is this Administration
this is going to happen anyway so it
gives credibility to it but say this the
Cy Hampshire is willing to consider to
put it in its portfolio
but I don't know I just don't want I
always thought I always had a problem
with crypto because I kept I was like
back from Superman you know it's like
crypto to me that's right that's right
it's it's a it's not a they don't know
the wrong they just ch the wrong the
wrong word for me but Cas never but
would have thought of that cry
cryptography cryptography that's short
I'm sure there was a good reason for
it so no you know this is just we you
another tool in the
toolbox um and you know we can say that
that we we have that capability
and but I don't expect this to happen
anytime soon that's what she said she
said yes I appreciate it and yes it's
nice to have there but it's probably not
going to happen tomorrow or maybe even
the next day she did say that a lot of
her colleagues around the country were
talking about it well that's the whole
thing they're all talking about it so
you you don't want you don't want to
ever feel that you're you've handicapped
the
treasure if there's something that that
that is it's something that they should
get involved in
so I think that we should just kind of
vote on it so ready for put someone in
the audience representative Ammon second
by representative
spear moves ought to pass on amendment
eight oh I'm
sorry uh yes you can comment yes we're
open
no no not the amendment I'm looking
at the amendment I'm looking at is
0138 oh I'm sorry yes go ahead sir
introduce yourself yeah Josh hips
attorney at the New Hampshire banking
Department we had fielded a question at
the last meeting of this regarding what
New Hampshire Banks would be allowed to
have on their balance sheet and I wanted
to provide a little more color to our
answer on that hempshire does not at
this moment have a positive or negative
regime yeah it's really close yeah I
have a positive or negative regime
regarding cryptocurrency or this type
assets statutorily defined we've not
taken a position on that what is
happening right now is the FDIC has
basically said no banks can't custody on
their balance sheet these type of assets
so New Hampshire itself does not
prohibit that and moving forward if we
begin to have this sort of regime we
would revisit that we would likely be
willing to Embrace that as a department
I can't speak for the industry as a
whole I imagine the industry will also
probably be interested in it but as a
department we have not taken any
position on this and so we basically
we're at the mercy of the FDIC because
the FDIC provides the insurance for
banks and so the banks basically cowed
what the FDIC wants them to
have so the bank commissioner has a seat
on the treasur board doesn't she that's
a good
question I
believe so the question is if the FDIC
would say no no then unfortunately she
might be compelled to have to then vot
the F if there was the treasure right
what the FDIC defines as a safe asset is
somewhat the tail that Wags The Dog and
so basically if the FDIC says no we do
not view this as a safe asset regardless
of what we at a state level might say
were comfortable with because they
provide the insurance the banks aren't
going to custody those assets if the
FDIC changes as it looks like they might
then we basically will have we will need
to revisit our statutes but our statutes
are silent at the moment regarding
cryptocurrency but we don't have any
place uh Josh hips and attorney at the
banking Department yeah how how do you
spell your last name hi p
ps I don't think we've ever met so no
I've always sit in the back with thanks
thanks for coming in thanks guys and
thanks for putting this on permanent
Forever okay the the likely uh use of
this would be an ETF product which would
be like a Fidelity or Black Rock product
and then they would custody it just be
basically buying the asset on the stock
exchange you know yeah and the technical
details will be handled for the treasur
no I I certain me
okay any other discussion on the motion
amended are you doing the amendment
first or just the whole thing we right
now we're doing the
amendment any discussion on the
amendment see none all those in favor
raise your hand one two three
here you think that was intentional
[Music]
or he said he was sick I think the
Ill but certainly makes the hearing
faster
okay six Zer six of us are
here so would you have six zero
circles John didn't vote did he I did I
have my hand on Paul voted but SEC he's
he's is he on it no he he didn't vote no
he's not yet oh he is on oh he was out
of the room okay you only had five or
four one two three four five five six
six I was right with the
six you have Ammon Maier her's not here
spear
prea
there's seven of us here okay there he
is we're good so what's the six is
zip all right uh representa Ammon second
by representative spear moves ought to
pass as amended any discussion on the
motion seeing not the clerk will call
the
role no
no we can do it up do no you don't call
I shouldn't have said that okay all
those in favor say I all right
1 two three four five six seven
seven I'm not yeah one two seven
Z
seven that was out all right and so who
who moved in you
had oh still the same one
okay so you're you're rewriting the
okay so now actually down here we write
that
am is
AD
ad
okay yeah so you're technically that was
there so you didn't need to do that so
yeah so you just checked this part
oh so you don't have to move it that's
exactly once you've done that then
next we will but it's we want to wait
that that that clock's a couple minutes
fast that clock is useless yeah it's
142 no I didn't stop and buy a new
clock but this hasn't been in my
committee room in a very long
time keth was was this bill um 639 was
this um other states have a version of
this
watch
[Music]
something
she she's not on the boat no
on and need is
not no she's
not
go okay so it this is the one that says
build number with no
this is
the no this is this is this is
just
work working copy as
amended well it will hopefully will be
[Music]
14 right we're
ready okay
all right so walk us through all right
thank you uh colleagues for letting me
walk you through this um the one thing I
do want to mention I sent an email
forwarded an email from Municipal
Association so the CH the changes that
you see there some of those are
from uh their comments
on it's Roman numeral
three
V3 I think the page number still work
page three right okay so page three line
30 it was where it starts go Carrie have
you seen all the
okay
good okay so we get through the
definition section
then then when we in page three line 13
that's where we start with the actual
statute that's right so we had an
extensive hearing on this um there were
questions from the committee but there W
there were
no people testifying against the bill
during the hearing so I mean whether
that's notable or not I'm not sure
but so there's a definition
section
um the infrastructure to run blockchain
protected so that talks
mine I'm sorry before that it's uh
holding the use of private digital
currency so it's just a a Prohibition on
Prohibition the self the self- custody
portion is
important okay but I'm just I'm I'm
ready any person should be allowed to
engage in home the IND complies with all
local noise ordinances so right out of
the
block excuse me expression out of the
block um right the GetGo that the the
focus is on the noise the theoretical
noise of
blockchain is that what I
and and just help me make sure I
understand the
noise isn't anything much more than the
air conditioners or whatever the cooling
for the make computers do big fans
mainly yeah if that's all it's about
it's so the chillers yeah chill right
the chips get hot and no you said
because
my uh uh my daughter she she works for
Schneider Electric which is uh where
they used to say the GE of France
and their whole focus on the computer
technology is the the racks and keeping
the racks cool it's all about the
chilling okay so so we're we're
identifying in paragraph one that the
issue is that somebody might have
complaints about the chillers so what
what it's saying is they must comply
with local any local whatever local
noise ordinances related so whatever the
decibel of the community pass the decb
right and there is a Chicken and the Egg
problem there because you know the
community might not pass it until there
is a noisy operation but that would
apply to anything right that would point
that the person who was doing it would
be grandfathered and that any new
ones couldn't have happened right I
mean okay I looked up the noise
ordinances in uh
nsha good place to start the noise
ordinances there do not do a decibel
thing okay what do they do they say no
loud radios no loud televisions no boom
boxes and no uh and and a sound created
in a building can't be heard 50 ft from
the building oh so this so now let me
get to this this law was written
I don't even know how many years ago
back probably when televisions were
invented
1947 problem we
have is that we have four huge apartment
buildings in in uh nashille with
hundreds of people living in those
apartment hundreds of Apartments we also
have multiple many multiple four family
units on one acre of a piece of land one
I'm sorry one eigh of an acre which
means 50 ft doesn't mean anything small
thing yeah very very small crammed in 50
50 50 ft don't mean anything tripple
Decker yeah it's it's really kind of
crowded over
there now I looked up to see if this was
a problem anywhere and apparently it is
it is turning out to be a problem in the
fact that in know let's say you have a
four family building which we have lots
of
one person can be using a lot of the
electricity can be generating a lot of
noise from air conditionings all that
kind of stuff so there's a company
called decentral and what they
specialize in is making uh
components that sound proof the
apartment or or or make sound baffling
energy control so that your computers
can only come on at night or whenever
you schedule them and to Supply Air
Conditioning if the problem wasn't
existing in an apartment building then
these guys wouldn't be making any money
cuz they're selling this stuff and
they're doing very well so my cons my
feeling about this is right now we don't
have we have specific law against TV
sets and a specific law against radio we
could very easily in the future possibly
end up with somebody who saying we got
to Outlaw this stuff not not Outlaw the
not Outlaw the residential mining so
much as you better put some baffling in
and you better to have some energy
controls such that you don't take down
the electricity for the entire little
complex that you're in so we don't know
what's going to happen in the
future and I don't think we should tie
our hands right now and say no right now
you're free to do whatever you want you
can do whatever you want nobody's done
it yet that it's noticeable so my
feeling is I think we got to leave
ourselves open that someday
somebody apparently this has become a
hobby that companies are making money
are you saying to wait till it comes the
prom yeah because we don't know what it
looks like we don't know what the
problem looks like and I'm worried about
apartment buildings and these four these
small multif family homes all cramped in
together and one on 1 E of an
acre so I think we have to make some
kind of a a thing and say well let's
let's see if they have a problem we
don't have a problem right now but maybe
we will can just a thought I I think
what you said uh Mr chairman was it that
if something was done today it would be
grandfathered if a new ordinance came in
correct why don't we remove that
grandfathering that would see you can't
you can't you can't remove grand grand
the whole point of grandfathering is
that if you you did something you were
in compliance with the current laws at
the time when you did something well
okay so it can't be and so you can't
come back and say oh well never
mind believe me North Conway is dealing
with this right now when it comes to
Vacation Rentals
but uh talk against car's point I again
we don't know when this might happen and
I don't think we want to wait I think
the whole purpose of this this bill is
to put New Hampshire in a good position
to uh to to be there when this stuff
really comes forward am I correct Keith
that's the thinking is to that we're
like a safe haven for the yeah you know
that because the you a a local example
recent local example is the state of New
York put a whole moratorium on mining
they didn't let so it was discriminatory
against one industry Statewide and it
sort of put a chilling effect on miners
setting up in New York so we we want to
say that that's not going to happen here
you know we're uh in addressing that
that particular issue there was a huge
mining operation set up on the Mohawk
River and it ended up using so much
electricity that they had to do
something they they waited until it got
to the point where they had to do
something what I'm saying is we don't
need we don't want to put in a law that
says we can't do something in the future
I can see not putting in a law right now
that says all right we're not going to
allow any mining that's it that's crazy
that's crazy we don't have a law that
says anything like that but we don't
want to take away from our ourselves the
ability to put a law in the future that
says don't take down all of the
electricity in this little apartment or
make a lot of rackets so nobody we're
not talking about electricity here I
know we're not but that's part of this
little thing that they go along with for
instance I I'm I'm focusing on the noise
okay just then just look at the noise
what I'm reading right now if you can't
hear about electricity okay but if you
can't sleep star starting a forest fire
and burning the whole town down because
too many trees around I wasn't even
talking about that I'm just saying that
people have issues with electricity high
tension that's another yeah we'll get to
that so let's let's let's think of this
another way it the issue here is um
that a draw a potential
drawback of digital mining is that it
has a sound problem that is a potential
problem okay
so um and as much as as I would say that
that
more understanding of zoning than I ever
did
before after going through with my
vacation rental business so what I'm
seeing here is that uh especially right
now we're all talking you know and set
up a whole committee committed to now
we're going to tell towns what they can
do zoning wise or can't do and that
struggle that zoning issue so what we're
looking at here is setting some ground
rules for towns or cities when it comes
to this kind of
activity and if the issue is really
sound if the issue is that is and it's
the chillers right the issue is the
chillers in my mind what we really want
to be doing I like the part
here that um no State Lo there shall set
a specific limit on sound decibel
generated from asset other than mining
other than limits set by a political
subdivision so the idea here is we're
giving direction to say is if somebody
wants to go into this business if
somebody wanted to do digital
mining are we going to just say oh free
you go go anywhere you want in New
Hampshire what we're saying is that um
our
fear is that some town would Zone
against it and create some zoning
regulation against it so what we want to
do is
ensure that um someone who opens one of
these businesses is uh is going to be
comfortable that they're that we the
state have have addressed the issue of
the
noise of the chillers and say that you
neighborhood right other words
say that that that and that now that
that's an anatha to me to start telling
people what you can and can't do but
it's just saying is that really where
we're going we're saying is if you're
going to put one of these things in you
got to put it in a place where it's
already going to we're assuming it's
going to be noisy it's it's an issue of
scale right so like I think Lisa or
represent post you have neighbors that
mine right I'm sorry yes we do you have
NE Neighbors in our town in your town is
there a noise problem I never hear it
I've actually got in their house and I
don't hear it because they have it down
in the basement and it's a small scale
thing right so it's a matter of scale
like the industrial scale is like
imagine like a Costco big chillers a
Costco that size all filed with they
could do their air conditioners yeah I I
I I think we're talking
about talk about
noise in
the there are people that have happened
in other
states where and in Texas is one of them
where in an apartment building they put
20 some odd computers in there and
they're turning on the air conditioning
and you wouldn't know until the noise
happened and it's just air conditioners
and what they're saying what I what I
think we should be saying well nashar
doesn't even have a noise ordinance that
would even address this because the only
things they call out are are radios and
televisions because that's all that's
ever happened in an apartment up to now
what I'm saying is if you decide to put
20 computers in your apartment building
and God knows what people put in their
apartment
buildings if you're going to make a lot
of noise then you have to put baffling
in or and there's other things that go
along with that what we're saying right
now and it may not apply to anything
else because inside of an apartment
building we don't typically generate a
lot of noise other than TVs and TVs and
uh radios this is going to be the first
time that we're seeing home people do
something in their apartments that they
haven't been doing before so my feeling
is we don't have a law against it now
let it go and if we run into a problem
we'll worry about it and address it when
it comes because then we'll know what it
looks like and the answer May simply be
well we're not going to Outlaw it just
put in some
baffling we don't know how we're going
to do it I hear you and here's my
problem my problem is what we're deing
right now with these zoning
regulations
okay this is totally zoning this bill is
everything about zoning and that is
that can
you have a computer in your home that's
doing this crash computer Computing okay
no no problem if you have couple
computers and you start having too many
computers and now and then let me put it
this way the battle over vacation rental
is that we're running a business we're
not just renting our house and it's that
it's the business element of it and so
in this case what this is talking about
is that yeah is is it just a hob to to
you know make
okay but the issue is H if it gets too
big it's too
much right in my case oh my God he's G
to have weddings there every night every
weekend okay and that's where I'm saying
the zoning balance this is a zoning
issue and that is what is appropriate
for that neighborhood if if somebody
just doing something in their basement
and nobody can hear it nobody knows
what's going on there's no problem it's
all of a sudden when they start scaling
up and before you know it they brought
they've got computers on other floors of
the house and before they know it the
next door neighbor uh you know is is
hearing all this noise that's going on
constantly then they then they'd have to
stop and then what they would do is they
would go to the zone board and say you
need a pass the zoning a to stop all
this noise
making okay so that's what I'm saying is
we got to think in terms of how are we
it is what is the where are we Drawing
the Line in terms of what is the
appropriateness of the activity and
where it's
happening hence that's why we have
industrial
zones industrial zones was here's where
noise
of
and right then they're not making
they're not exceeding the noise or
ordinances once the baffling goes in
right baffling is that's what baffles me
because because what you're saying is
that you've done something to solve the
problem okay but the next door neighbor
those how would I put it lightly might
be someone is it doesn't matter they
really just don't like these people
doing what they're doing and they want
to shut it down and they're going to
make a complaint and now the
selectman are in the zoning officers in
an awkward position because he says it
doesn't seem that bad to me but the
neighbor say oh my God can't you hear
that noise or or maybe you should come
back here on when it's a moonless night
and and noise really carries you suggest
I I'm just trying to identify the
problem and I'm trying to figure out
what we're trying to legislate for and
then figure out how's the best way to
fix that problem but I think this solves
the problem as we know it today it
doesn't mean the problem might be
different in the future but that doesn't
mean we have to wait to the Future to
decide I I don't think I do not think
that we need to make a uh not pass this
bill because you know XYZ is going to
happen in the future that doesn't make
sense to me yeah I'm not big on
prophylactic legislation okay they're
trying to you know try to close the barn
door before the horse gets out but I'm
what I'm interested intrigued by what
this bill is about is um
can the home Happy
homeowner do something and still not be
a problem and and remember include
renters in that in big complex apartment
buildings okay and then versus we all
agree that if they had just move this
operation over into the industrial zone
or whatever the town oh that's certainly
then there was no problem then there is
no problem so what we're trying to
address I assume is the mom and pop shop
that the home the home business is that
really what the problem we trying to
address here it's just it's more than
that you can't use the if this passed
the a a municipality couldn't
use noise ordinances as a
directed as a methodology to try to shut
them down they have to be treated the
same as any other except that Nash was
has directed ones now that's the way
they do it they say radios and they say
televisions and so therefore or they
could easily add and they can easily add
add they could easily add uh in the
future uh if it becomes a problem
chilling chillers for conditioners and
that's what this bill is going to try to
address is to tell them what they can or
can't add it's just to treat mining
fairly and you know mining there is
mining happening in the state um now in
homes in homes and in you know the
proposed amended language is much
simpler from the original so just
realize a lot of that's crossed out and
it's
Incorporated uh what the municipal
Association passed on this is what this
is their notes right this is from their
notes and and I emailed I forwarded
everybody that email I I got I got the
notes that one I that email I did read
yeah yes I did read that email yes you
did so if that if the municipal
Association is comfortable with this and
they're not here but if this is what
they're comfortable
with okay not that I'm am a friend of
the municipal Association I am not we
love the municipal
Association not that I they are and I on
the same level about about the
residential unit that the idea is that
this this is in the language in here is
enforceable in their minds for a town to
add to they zoning
regulations like I say all NASA has to
do is add on there yeah how that's
discriminating I don't see how that's
not discriminating if I call out now I
could I could uh talk about
discriminating they just banned boom
boxes in their ordinance yeah they did
think I think they're saying that so
that isn't that discriminatory yeah but
this says calling it out
specifically or maybe I think they could
write a law that that nothing could
would exceed the the decb or or the
sound of a boom box or anything else so
this would have to comply within those
rules so whether it's it's the you know
the mining or but they haven't made
those laws yet and now you're telling
them they got to change and they don't
know how to they don't know where they
going they ABS is a big city they're big
boys they can they can they can
certainly if let me put it this way I if
the municipal
Association saw follow this language and
said this is workable which says set a
specific limit on sound decb generated
okay in your in your mind you're saying
is Well they don't have that yet okay
but they still have the limits if we
pass this
bill I'll bet you you'll have it within
a
year because we have set the guidelines
you don't know nashille no but that and
that's and that's another is Nash runs
the state
no it
doesn't no I you're looking at it the
other way around I I would every
sometimes we can look at things from do
two different directions that is true
and the problem I'm having is that we
don't have an issue right now we're
putting in a
law when we don't know what it's going
to look like but we don't have an issue
right now we don't have an issue so why
I put in a law to create an issue okay
but let's say the issue happens tomorrow
let's say that that
tomorrow somebody in
Nashua in their basement not their
basement in the apartment next to mine
in the apartment next to yours which I
don't have okay suddenly puts this the
mother of all air conditioners in their
window they put in this
big mother of an air conditioner and now
it's driving you nuts right and you're
going to call and you're going to call
the Nashua and and the and they're going
to say is well we don't Rec regulate
that's what they they're going to look
at that statute and say we never
regulated that right okay and you think
they're just going to say so too bad
constituent citizen of Nashua or they
going to say
is you know you're right we probably
should have thatat guess you didn't see
any thing about the asphal
plant the only way that they got that
from happening was to go to go to
court now what was that a noise or or
smell that was pollution and everything
else it was in an industrial Jone it was
in an industrial Zone and they had no
laws against it like we don't have now
and if they did something the only way
nashaa said was let's go to court that's
the only way they could get anything to
change it wasn't anybody nicely sitting
there saying oh well this sounds
ridiculous let's go change it and what
was their basis of their court case what
was what did they had to be pollution
okay
so is that what we're going to have to
do this it I I no no we're opposite of
each other now
around I don't see how what you what you
know putting in a law now for something
you don't know what it looks like I have
to say is normally I'm not into
prophylactic legislation you know to try
to do it trying to Bar close the barer
before but that having the state say
ahead of time before anybody has passed
the
zoning saying ahead of time this is what
you need to do you telling the I'm we're
by passing if we were to pass this
sentence set a specific limit on sound
decb generated from home digital asset
mining other than limit said I mean and
you don't even need to say home digital
assets but you can say setting sound
limits on
decimals generated for
including home digital asset
mining by the limits of a political
subdivision that sounds better okay just
simply saying it's not we're not saying
it's just digital asset it's it can be
anything that makes noise pollution we
are giving them advice that maybe you
want when you put it the way when you
put it the way you just said
you
happy I pull rabbits out of the Hat all
the
time they're they're mentioning let's
say televisions and radios in here they
don't mention bugles so I mean a guy can
get up on the roof of uh the building
and start blowing the the fugle and what
somebody would say wait a minute that's
making no more noise than you're louded
to because there more noise than than a
TV or radio makes this is covered by
that no it is not it is we'll have to go
to court on oh no this wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute which what
do you mean by this who is this I'm just
saying that this basically says you
can't feed the the local noise
ordinances that's what it says don't
both way yeah it wor both way can we
vote on this I I uh well we there's
still more this whole sentence has got
to be reworked but I'm open to reworking
it the whole the whole sentence is SE
everybody and and I I actually
uh agree with you that we should take
somewhat take the digital asset act
aspect out of this bill and be more like
a
guidance okay and and normally I would
say this well let's should go to
the municipal and County government but
we don't want to send it off to another
committee we we'll fix this on our own
and we'll get their blessing but I think
that it that if we just it's not about
digital asset it's about anybody who's
got a home business that might make a
lot of noise it doesn't have to be
business don't make it a business it
could be a hobby it's a it's a h home
excuse me home activity that makes too
much damn noise that'd be fine I I would
like to leave the word the term digital
Assets in there expand it including okay
including we going to postpone this then
or just we're still working we're
working the language only one so I know
so some of you weren't here for the this
morning so so basically um is this an
early bill or not uh what's the bill
what's the what is the bill number in
this
639 okay an early bill means we have to
get out of committee early because it's
going to go to a second
commit what makes it an early bill it's
the fiscal note and no no it has nothing
to do with the fiscal no Oh I thought it
was okay I'll leave I'll leave my mic on
for this one okay an early bill
is that whoever is sitting in the
speaker's
office and Paul Smith is usually in the
room and years ago used didn't even he
used to be just staffer so it could have
been just Aaron okay whoever's sitting
in that room they read the
bill they're supposed to pay attention
to the rsas which sometimes I we couple
bills we've had back to the committee
because they weren't paying attention to
the RSA but they are paying attention
that they look at that statute and then
say well which committee should get this
bill and they go well this bill should
go to Commerce because it's dealing with
assets well this bill also
has and I hate to say it you know zoning
I mean they got
criminal penalties I mean to be honest I
have no idea what they do and how they
decide um it's supposed to be and and
over my years I've had this conversation
it's supposed to be they're looking at
the
rsas okay in this case you got you know
359 that well that I think that's us
anyways that's um consumer protection
but they they look at the penalties and
they'll say is all right this needs to
go to two
committees has nothing to do with the
fiscal note if it had an a appropriation
it absolutely the second committee would
be
Finance but if it says FN FN simply
means that that they sent it to at least
one or more departments to generate a
fiscal note but the only way you know
it's going to do a seconding committee
is that you have to have this little
secret secret report this Secret
Squirrel report that
only that only staff and chairman can
secret it's it's not a secret anymore
now right okay it is it is not it is it
is it is not obvious no it isn't it is
not obvious you just get yeah I know
what this is going no it is not obvious
and unfortunately as a chairman I have
to uh take
my
instructions and says this bill has to
go out early because it's going to a
second committee too bad okay too bad
okay now the interesting part about that
is there have been times when the
committee gets it out early and then and
finance waves yeah we you seen that on
the floor there we oh we don't we don't
need to take it after all okay so having
said that um this bill is supposed to go
to a second committee it might go to
Municipal I don't know it doesn't matter
all I know is we have to vote this out
of committee on the 5th because the 6 is
a session day and we can't do it on the
six so we have to do it on the 5th and
uh so we want to amend it we want to do
whatever we can to to make it it
comfortable for this committee Commerce
comfortable to send this bill forward
otherwise we could retain it and we
would work on it in September it would
come out in January and delay okay so
the issue right now is for saying this
can be
fixed because what we're doing is we're
we're taking this the viice of the
municipal Association not that you have
any love spirit for them okay but that
we can at least say what we're really
care about is we don't we're not
labeling this an activity as a hobby
versus business or whatever it is but
whatever they do if the town wants to
limit what's going
on using
decies
said otherwise the town might not Zone
anything
it just this is talking about how no
town can make it uh pick on them pick on
that industry so what we want to just
rephrase it and rather than making a
picking on the industry is that that
that it's the sound is
certainly allowed to set decimal
limits but but that um and and including
digital assets we're just setting some
ground rules but if they they want to
way how about some
Scottish ppes
okay all right so we want to have in
there just rephrase that sentence to
similian sound
decibels uh um from any noise including
house digital asset mining other than
subdivision so don't pick on anybody
else we okay with that could you repeat
that I'll type it in my set a specific
limit on sound decimals generated from
noise from noise
including home digital asset and I think
you might want to drop the word home I
think that I was thinking the same thing
to lead the word home just say including
digital asset mining other than the
limits set by a political subdivision
set a specific limit on sound decimals
generated from any noise in in comma
including digital asset mining comma
other than the limits set by the
political subdivision in any local noise
ordinances what's that yeah right any
just took out one word I okay we're
looking at you got it in front of
you yeah to right now it says set a
specific limit on sound decb generated
from
noise in comma
home right including
bugles all generated from noise well you
know I think that then setting the
limits set by a political subdivision
might like that sounds a little
confusing to me but so generated from
noise
noise from the building to the outside
world that's where they set the limits
from the building outside
world where the problem comes in is
inside of an apartment building it may
never get to the outside world but it's
driving everybody on that floor
insane so it's not
just the the building or whatever
structure it's in it has to be it could
be internal to the building because
there's multiple people but that would
be the limits set by a political
subdivision you could have a a which is
confusing I agree with you so um I I uh
we I need to let me work with uh the
municipal Association to get the a good
phrasing but that what you wanted to say
is we don't want a political Au we want
neighbors can I can I ask you a question
so if you're an apartment someone has
kids several kids and they put an air
conditioner in
every window what's the uh when you set
up if you have enough computers you're
putting in multiple air condition and
internal it's a different kind of air
window get zoning zoning is from a
political subdivision right but in an
apartment complex or condo complex
there's other governance that happens
they got their own rules they got their
own rules and that this this won't even
apply to that I'm I'm assuming that
phrase set by the political
subdivision is a zoning term I'm
assuming that but we don't have any
zoning people
here can I call somebody the municipal
Association get their buns down here I I
don't think that's correct I think that
do you have his phone number in the
apartment you're going to have other
rules and I don't well
but yeah but you can't have Nashville go
and tell every apartment building what
they've got to have for rules internally
oh
internally well that's that's NASA's job
to do
that Nas's
talk yeah we're talking about the zoning
we're talking about the zoning of the
town I would have to say with my limited
experience over the years zoning around
regulations around noise noise has been
is complicated it's not because most of
the time it's this one guy who who Who's
got this Hemi with with a very noisy
engine and has to hit his you know and
and do that so in this case what
concerns me about your concern is let's
say some guy's got a really old air
conditioner that's got that
noise clicky noise okay and that clicky
noise is so loud that the next door
news I bet you it comes up all the time
and they just told the person tough
bananas buy him a new air conditioner
killing this we're killing this okay we
all need to know that that paragraph
needs some more that sentence needs some
work all
right maybe we should take a field trip
to one of these
places okay we're on to the next set all
right uh imposing requirement um that
does not equally apply to an industrial
Zone properties we don't have a problem
right
right okay all right okay let me let me
repas it so you I know that youve read
this on so now I'm on page
problem uh I guess or no agency May
establish a rate schedule for digital
asset of money that creates a
discriminatory rates for digital asset
that's to do with electricity rates
electricity rates yeah
okay okay you assume you don't have a
problem with that
we're right now on line seven on page
four it's the new number where you um
you no no they won't do they they're
highly regulated by the Public Utilities
Commission fine okay all right now we're
on to V4 right to private keys
okay tell us about your problem with
private
Keys it's an RSA but
account there it
is it's RSA 595 did a Col
six and I read that RSA and what's in
here is tighter than that now ordinarily
I would think that maybe we
don't we don't know what or we should
have something then I went and looked up
my
new investigation is found
spaning
apparently crypto is now used
extensively the porn
characterize you know what the
internet's used for all kinds of
Nefarious things too right so let me
just get to my point
my they use tokens to put in content and
they use a different set of tokens to
buy the
content where I have problem is if this
is what's going on in the regular world
you call porno the regular world it's on
the regular internet I you get oh oh the
tokens that let's say Microsoft has with
their games and these kids have byy they
get tokens and they win tokens do you
think we're going to get into regulating
that no that's not the point that's not
the point the point is how far behind
are we I'm finding child point and so
the idea somebody uses a blockchain to
do illegal activities we need why do we
want a law that's tighter than what's
already existing for bank
accounts in order to get information the
language of the bill says
um Roman numeral 2 a court May compel
disclosure of private key only if the
party seeking compulsion demonstrates a
clear and convincing evidence that the
information or acts of assault cannot
reasonably be attained by through other
means and that lack of disclosure will
lead to Ill rep able harm so when you're
talking about irreparable harm this has
compel this is this is more like having
cash in a safety deposit box like bank
account's a third party this this is not
involving third parties so I think we
should beting any
laws that make anything
any
harder for them to investigate whatever
illegal activities they need to
investigate so what is what is the RSA
that you're referring to that's already
have we have another seat over here for
you what's that say
again it's
the you want to five 5 95 95
d
a colon six that's the in which they can
bank comp they can compel the bank to
comply this is compelling you to give up
a secret might just be in your mind
right give the account number well so
your public key would be similar to your
account number it wouldn't allow them to
move the funds but it would allow to see
what where the funds are flowing right
so I way I look at this is that it's
saying is no one should be compelled to
give up information unless somebody's
taken them to
court and the court says you got to you
got to show it you got to give us your
your password and we have a and and so
therefore you just want this to this
right to private Keys refer to RSA 595
A6 or something like that okay no more
restrictive than that okay well we'll
consider it look into it just related to
that look into I mean this is
about digital private Keys sorry I SC
let me read
59 marvels of computers okay A6 this is
uh an officer of EX search warrant but
for some other o men finds property or
empowered to take he shall seize and
safely keep them under direction of the
Court yeah so this under under the
guidance of the
statute in other words that that
exemption that you're looking there for
part two you would just want to refer to
9686 okay uh yeah oh good you know
something about this perfect that's what
I need more of so you know something
just quick comment on this
yes great all right and youran tell
everybody your name yes Ian huid here is
a volunteer board member of New
Hampshire blockchain Council and just to
clarify the the reason you would want
actually stronger protections for
private Keys than you would want for a
bank account is a bank account is
controlled by responsible third party a
bank if someone compromises my bank
information you know they've got my
debit card number they've got my routing
number I can call the bank and they can
bail me out potentially and and at least
greatly mitigate the harm whereas if
someone gets my private keys I'm done
that's it so there is a a tremendous
qualitative difference and that's at
least the reason why you would argue
that private Keys Merit greater
protection because if they are
compromised in some way you're just
toast there's no you know Bank customer
support line that can come and help you
we're not talking about somebody getting
compromised by Joe Frank walking down
the street we're talking about a legal
case in which there is suspected illegal
activity and a court is involved right
we're not talking about just anybody
walking off the street and stealing
somebody's referring to the paragraph
two court May compel disclosure of a
private key only if the party seeking
compulsion to demonstrates by clear and
convincing evidence the information or
access S can cannot be rained through
other
means that's where I have the problem
other means means that now words the
state can get that information without
them I want it I like it to say that the
same thing is
whats the court shall impose appropriate
projection ensure the disclosures
no the prevailing part's legitimate
interest
but I think we should make a reference
to the
59586 I think so too you you follow me
with that 59886 has basically it's a
search warrant statute sure and and
there would be protections for your bank
account under the Fourth Amendment but
the the distinction with private keys
and and the reason many people think
there should be special statutory
protections around private keys that are
especially protective and have something
like an irreparable harm standard is
once any other person besides me has my
private Keys then the security of my
private Keys is is just done right and
it's very hard to start over whereas
there is you can't change your private
Key Well I mean in theory you could you
could potentially come up with a work
around that you can't change your
password every day yeah it's I mean it's
not like it's not like a password or
it's not like you're you're routing them
so if if I compromise your private keys
and I move the funds then you're done I
I own you don't get the funds you if you
have a copy of my private ke and someone
sees it and gets access to it and moves
my funds then I'm also done so it's it's
very important that they're that they're
held securely and there's not going to
be a stop order for example so I would
argue the the it says the court shall
impose appropriate protection to ensure
the disclosure is no broader than is
necessary to serve the prevailing
party's legitimate interest right so
that's we're going to leave that in
there but we just still want to give
them the right to get access to it which
is what
59586 sets out the parameters to get
access and I would say I don't want to
overstay my welcome but I would say uh
an irreparable harm standard would do
that in any of the kinds of serious uh
criminal cases that we're talking about
here I mean clear and convincing
evidence that's that doesn't require
conviction you don't need to to Pro
prove Beyond A Reasonable Doubt someone
has committed a crime it's just got to
be um because it's much more sensitive
and much more destructive than when you
get into a bank account account it's got
to be probably high standard than
language here this section was this
picked up by any other statute was there
another state that has the same yeah
this is model law from and a few other
states have adopted it it's in the other
um Basics laws that representative Ammon
referenced Oklahoma is one I I can't
remember the other recent one you
mentioned as well okay thank you okay
if this was also Port let's talk about
some other states okay Mississippi
Nebraska Ohio Oklahoma with the first
version of it Tennessee both the Senate
and the house all rejected it all reject
this whole
bill I mean that's not a reason for us
to reject it and I'm not they did reject
it last year and they they probably what
did they write in the blurb about what
their committee report what was in their
committee report I.E the some of them
they never wrote a committee report they
did a uh failed to journ which means
they just the committee without ever
acting on it well what kind of states or
do that oh I can't imagine we don't do
that we you got to give an explain the
reason you're I read our
reports actually only one of them
actually made it to a vote so Oklahoma
and Louisiana they've both passed the
bill in full in my understanding and uh
so you can find some that passed I can
find some where it failed well you're
trying to kill the bill I'm trying to
pass the bill no what I want to do is
add the Restriction of RSA 595 d a Col 6
to that one thing and then I'm
okay I thought we just did I I want to
add the language of 595 A6 into this
paragraph then I'm okay and I won't
bring up the other I'd like to research
it more just having heard it for the
first time now and and I'm I'm open to
it I'd like to we're working on it we're
working on it okay all right we're on to
now blockchainbased trust recognized so
you any problem with that paragraph what
four this is line 19 the only thing I
would say about that is hopefully we're
going to have on and with
hp310 a uh committee to investigate uh a
commission to set up to come up with
some laws regarding uh stable coin and
real world assets and I'm wondering if
this might be better handle there
although this is strictly blockchain
which could be crypto which is not
necessarily stable coin or the other one
so where at what where at this is the
committee that does this now no no it's
the commission well the commission's
already did it that's where this this
bill came from this section no it did
not wait wait it didn't come from this
commission no this is a this is from a
uh a model legislation that went around
to a bunch of States no that's incorrect
hold on a second um this blockchain the
blockchain trust is a novel it's not in
any
model she's not talking about trust yet
I think she's still you still on this
par about the private Keys paragraph
you're on the trust okay this is this
bill in total some of the
recommendations came from the crypto
commission uh the um the blockchain
docket is specifically one of the
recommendations some other pieces of it
like the private Keys the zoning stuff
came from model legislation uh
this uh section about blockchainbased
trusts is no other state has even
attempted this this is a new a new idea
and it's based on precedent in law you
can see it references other statutes
quite frankly I think we should have
something like that and I I'd almost say
that we should break it out and make it
its own law so it isn't lumped in with
the with the rest of the stuff because
it's it's a pretty important kind of a
piece especially with blockchain being
uh you mean want to put it into the
trust
law I'm not an expert on trust law I
don't know where it goes well I
sponsored it you know what the Godfather
of the trust law if we're not
comfortable with this
piece maybe we we take this and put it
as part of the the study commission 310s
study and and we can we can do a little
more uh cuz there's some there's some
Confluence of of uh you know the
definition of decentralization is very
foundational to this piece and also the
stable coin stuff so you know that
thing okay if that's what it takes then
uh we'll give it to the
commission and we have trust experts you
know the the chair of the crypto
commission basically helped write our
trust law
and uh yeah so he's uh and we've been
talking to him about this who we talking
about Bill aringer oh yeah bill yeah
Bill's the man yeah Bill's the man okay
okay so we'll let Bill's commission
figure that one out okay could we let uh
attorney hwit just speak to this want to
this hit your mic of course yes red red
for on I still haven't figured that out
after few years red is red is go yeah
exactly uh this one so I've actually
I've made a blockchainbased trust uh as
an attorney here in New Hampshire and
I've got a published law review article
on on trust through the blockchain and I
think one of the main reasons this is in
here is that kind of the goal
overarching goal of this bill as I see
it is to just check a few boxes of very
lwh hanging fruit where we can make New
Hampshire more blockchain friendly
through increased kind of clarity and
neutral protections that are not big
steps and New Hampshire is already a
very um friendly state in terms of trust
and self-settled asset protection trust
law when I passed it it was the first
state to do it and and this uh this kind
of does what representative spear was
suggesting earlier with Banking and just
kind of takes our existing statutes and
just says and also you can do this over
the blockchain um the right now um
self-settled asset protection trusts or
what they're called irr irrevocable
spendthrift trust in our law come from
the common law of impossibility correct
as I I take it many of you know and then
our statutes also just take that common
law and rearticulate it and clarify that
if you kind of forfeit your own control
over your own money and it's legitimate
courts are going to recognize that and
that clarification even though that was
common law in New Hampshire already was
done in statute to bring more business
into New Hampshire this would also do
that with blockchain and I would suggest
it really wouldn't change any outcome of
any case uh if I was litigating on
behalf of a client who had set up a
self-settled asset protection trust
through the blockchain I think any
lawyer who knows anything about this
area would tell you at the end of the
day I'm going to win that case in New
Hampshire with or without this but the
difference is without it I and other
lawyers like me are going to make more
money needlessly arguing cross motions
motions for summary judgment Discovery
um where whereas if you just clarify it
you kind of cut out that practice area
attract more business and create more
incentive and Clarity for for people in
this area to come into the state uh
believe it or not you just gave the for
speech I gave when I wrote the trust law
okay because everything was case law and
I was cutting we're cutting out the the
heavy lifting of case of lawyers having
to go through and figure out the case
law and that was the purpose of the
trust act having said that um I had like
100 lawyers in the room when I was
drawing this stuff up and they all of
them had you know 106 opinions so so I
would say is that yeah I hear you but
yes I'd like to have those those legal
beagles to go through this and make sure
that they feel comfortable that this is
appropriate to be stuck in the trust
side I remember reading your committee
report so it's not a coincidence so are
you're thinking in terms of moving it
over to the commission well just we
could pull this out now
and and I mean if nothing else I'll I'll
bring in as a separate bill for next
year but that you know it's it's I want
I want to make sure the idea of it is
trust people trust people right place
yeah okay thank you good idea Keith well
I think this is this would be a novel
thing that no other state has tried and
it fits it fits nicely with New
Hampshire that's why I want to do it
because you want to sponsor it when I TR
so we will take this out of the bill
okay this section will come out of the
V5 would come out of the bill I I
remember it come out of the bill and
then we will they will they will give it
to the commission it'll be of the bill
what are we going to do well we're
almost there we're we're now down to
V6 processing regarding blockchain
networks yeah and so you'll see on I'm
on page five right yes and some bold
face stuff there so I I think
the the the Roman numeral 2 and three
the old one I I think we could probably
get rid of that because it's redundant
it's already there already is an
exemption in 399 G that we've had since
2017 it's been recodified oh Money Train
yeah we already so I I mean do we I
don't maybe we want to State it
explicitly so it's there or but it's not
necessary in my
feedback it's I guess it doesn't H
you're just repeating what's already
statute right right are you taking up
the L so these all these yeah two three
and
four yeah right yeah two two two and
three is what I have right y just two
and three the 399 G I mean it's it might
be helpful to someone reading the wall
that you know well but this is Page Six
right yeah we're on page five and you
can see that highlighted
okay
um oh it it it makes the references to
the statutes that that did it which is
fine just leave them in it's it's fine
leave so we're leaving call them yeah
just leave that in all right because
they're yeah they're fine because
they're they're already law right and
they're just they're just like if
somebody if somebody thought they might
have to be you know registered as a
transfer see that no they
don't because it back in commodity it is
not legal
tender okay moving on to Roman numeral
five
is so not face liability related to a
specific TR merely by validating that
transaction yeah so validating is part
of the protocol so if you're running a
node transactions are coming through
your node and if you're you know if
you're if you're validating a
transaction you you might be the first
to add it to the blockchain or you might
be validating what others have already
added to the blockchain that there's no
liability for you just simply validating
transaction that's that's what a node
does okay right so
it's all right can I ask yeah and I I I
kind of agree with that I mean it makes
sense but in the cases where illegal
concerned can there be any liability
with respect to
that you know if a block change is being
used if you are the person initiating
the transaction then yes you might have
liability if you're doing something
nefarious and you're the you're moving
your own funds but just because the
blockchain is validating it doesn't mean
that I know what you're saying yeah all
right this is okay
civil basically a loser pays
right uh well that's
yeah and it references the blockchain
dispute docket which will talk
about yep it's fine cability it's a
Clause gives us off the hook for the
whole
bill right and blockchain dispute docket
yeah so this was one of the major
recommendations from the final report in
the crypto uh commission and it's
basically if you think about Delaware
being the the you know the the king
court right they have their own
chancellory court and that's one of the
reasons why you want to U potentially
register an a corporation in Delaware
because they have that dispute
resolution they have the knowledge they
don't have the trust law they just have
case law just case law and they have
lots of case law everybody's at a
corporation
Delaware and so this language comes from
the business dispute docket and attorney
huitt explained this very well during
the public hearing the language is
really just a lift of the business
dispute docket which exists and replaces
it with blockchain and requires that
there be some technical expertise uh
that the the judge presiding should have
some technical expertise and in the
beginning it might not be used very much
so that judge can do can also uh hear
other cases unrelated to blockchain but
that at least the industry knows if they
have a dispute that there is uh you know
a judge and a docket specifically for
blockchain and you can see based on the
definitions and all the concepts that
we're talking about that you need some
expertise to you know be judicious in
you know resolving disputes or deciding
cases so that's the idea behind the
dispute you what the lift is the
business dispute docket there's language
and statute that establish the business
dispute docket that's a real thing that
exist yeah we have our TR court now we
now have a statute so so the the
language that established that we
repurposed and replaced it with
blockchain and it's to satisfy the
recommendation in the in the crypto
commission
report so it's it's sort of like just uh
taking a model that has already worked
and repurposing it specifically for
blockchain does it cost any money to set
up a
docket theoretically there's an
allocation of a
judge and but you know the the court
system always says they don't have
enough judge but they they always make
it so we don't pay attention to that we
ignore
them
so and then the the effective dates so
section four that's the dispute docket
that's January 1st
2026 and then everything else is 60 days
after passage so it gives the court some
time to
you know contemplate how they're going
up
right okay so going
here
uh original we're going
to fix on page
three the state local agency subdivision
thereof
shall and we'll make sure that it's uh
it's about giving them a GU guidance and
zoning
and then on page
four um they have some stuff they struck
out and then we have a reference we want
to reference the right to private Keys
reference the uh procedural process of
we're going to take uh the V5
blockchainbased trust recognition take
that out of the bill at this point and a
give it to the commission and and B run
it through the legal beagles and see if
we can uh put in a separate bill for
next year get that
going
and that's
it okay we still have another
subcommittee so you have plenty of
chance to
it exact where I'm I'm going to have
legislative Services help me write the
write that out
okay do we do anything with this uh
extensive conversation going through the
line all right you all right Keith good
yeah thank and thank you for everyone's
patience going through this um we'll
knock a whole bunch out at once and then
we don't have to hear it again so thank
you we're not any determination no we're
not doing anything because this will be
another subcommittee once we get the
amendment
dra okay all right what do we got
left paint 451 I love this paint people
Jes I want to get home I'm not I'm not
coming in tomorrow just for one bill in
the
morning have just one bill well on for
me just one bill if you're in the Liquor
Commission you got bills in the
afternoon yeah you're going to be okay
D I don't
know
Jackson you're up there you know if it's
I don't mind sow I think
it's well I I I just get out early and
uh go on the highway doesn't bother me
that
much
okay we'll open up the subcommittee on
um okay so I think that the biggest
Bugaboo is funding
mechanism
um and the way I saw it was the The
Entity that does this collecting or
setting this up is an organization that
is created by paint
manufacturers and therefore it only
seems rational that the paint
manufacturers shouldn't
be wasting their time with the state of
New Hampshire and regul and this is
their organization that they should just
pay for it
directly and way I I guess in the bill
the I read the bill is that the initial
monies was that they are going they were
going to it front the money so why not
just front the money and then pass on
the cost of managing this entity that is
Theirs to collect the paint why don't
they just pay for it and and have and
we'll all be happy happy isn't that what
they did though I think that's what no
they have a fee at the point of
sale there wasn't a but they don't have
to do that I that's not the way I
understood it the way I understood it
okay is that it would just simply add if
a gallon of paint was 30 bucks then this
they the retail value would be 3150 or
something like that it wouldn't be 30
bucks plus you're paying 150 yes it was
built into it just like with her liquor
yeah stuff that's the way I understood
it well that that's not the way it was
CL okay so he you need a mic sorry
because your your words are going to be
button um thank you representative hunt
um my name is Jeremy Jones hold a little
Clos my I'm softspoken you got own soken
you got to own the mic yeah uh Jeremy
Jones um I'm the director of extended
producer responsibility for American
codings Association coding assoc right
um yeah that's that's who I am so happy
to answer any questions I have uh been
on the operation side of this program in
multiple States um including Minnesota
um where I used to live for 20 years so
I'm real familiar with all these is kind
of I can clear up any claric you know
anything that's misconceptions or
anything so how does it actually work
how does the program actually work so it
is like this the you you were correct in
saying that it's very similar to how the
beer Tax Works here in um in in New
Hampshire where the manufacturer um is
obligated by law to add a certain amount
of money to um or in this case in the
beerx it's a distributor but there's a
different distribution model for for
paint but just you know manufacturer
Andor distributor is obligated to add um
whatever this cost is to the price that
is paid by the retailer when it takes it
into inventory and then that is then
Incorporated in the price that they are
paid that that is paid by the customer
um so yeah it is is is in that same vein
um I think where the hangup might have
might have been is about the display of
any particular fee on a receipt you know
um the fee tries to give a retailer an
option to know about this I think what I
maybe heard because I watch the
testimony from afar good last time was
that maybe there was an issue with that
option and not giving the option to the
retailer to B
basically be silent on that and
just let the mystery be so to speak like
as with the beer tax is that fair to
say um the beer tax is invisible that is
true that the consumer has no idea that
there was a beer tax involved yes so
sorry and and uh so in a sense that you
are going to show us because I I don't
read it but that way so maybe you can
show me where it is in the bill but that
it says that this the fee is going to be
part of um the wholesale price is going
to be added to the wholesale price and
so the retailer the even the retailer so
I would I call it it's almost like a vat
tax are you familiar with the way
Europeans do their value added tax it's
added uh at at the time transfer from
the wholesaler to the
retailer the the fee is ADD added to it
but in my case when because we don't
have a beer distributor system right and
then and then basically you're building
it into your wholesale price correct and
and in the sense that um you know it is
illegal for manufacturers to
unilaterally increase their prices that
isn't somewhat what compels this to be
written into statute and that
manufacturers would would like to put
put this cost but you know again it
would be violation of antitrust laws to
do so well that's only if you're calling
it a something that that all the are
doing together but if you are uh
treating it as a cost of goods sold is
this as a cost of do doing business and
that part of your business is uh one in
some cases you might have one of your
businesses did you have a um you send
one of your mark your people they come
in and help build a the display in the
store and how it's displayed and shown
okay in this case you are providing a
service that has that's going to come in
and pick up all this paint that was left
over okay and and taking care of it so
it has there's no direct connection to
this being a
uniform uh
responsibility that that that affects
the antitrust laws okay which is why I
think you're referring to but that this
is just a cost of doing business then
you are rolling in your business because
for some you know you know you might
have a variable payment schedule about
how you handle the paint in different
paints and how you with the type of
paint who knows what you might do and
how to dispose this stuff I just don't
want to get in the business of measuring
it or quantifying it or putting any
dollar valot to it so I just don't want
it in a statute you know I want this to
all be transparent you're taking care of
this behind the scenes and it's just a
cost of doing business John Page two
me e
GBS I don't want to know if it Fe me
frankly I don't even think we need the
legislation frankly you guys can just go
ahead and do this and you don't need us
at
all yeah
except the last page
what's the last
page yes I'd love to talk about the last
page okay so page five line 7 through
14 seems like you want to skirt the
state laws converting solvents into
Universal
waste and then 10 through 14 you want us
to take away all responsibility if
there's
any spill or
so that this particular provision you're
talking about 149 m73 post consumer
paint for houses and small businesses y
so this is this is um I may not be the
best person to speak on this I I
understand that as I as this is a
provision that um really covers the
challenges of accepting this
material um you know as it it would be
delivered to a retail location it's more
to in this in every state that this
program operates it operates in 13
states covering a third of the United
States um there are usually some rules
around handling of paint that need to
dis ways what's that asard is way
sometimes it is sometimes it isn't and
these are um you know typically re rules
that somebody else you can have somebody
else do it you don't have to do this
just simple sure just simple to say that
it enables the program to
function as intended makes the program
to
cop take thanks so is this a new
employee from Dees we never met before
I've never been in front of this
committee before not uh my name's pisit
I'm uh the Hazardous Waste Management
Bureau
administrator so in order for a can you
spell your last name please oh p i s k
oov i
TZ and it's Todd t o
d okay great welcome to the Congress
committee thanks um
downsized in order for a business in New
Hampshire to collect a household
hazardous waste they would typically
become a uh a generator of hazardous
waste so Most
states I don't know about most but many
states household hazardous waste is
exempt from regulation from Cradle to
grave in New Hampshire households are
exempt from the regulation but once they
bring it to a collection facility that
facility is now the generator of that
hazardous waste that's not the case in
every
state most paints are latex paints and
they're not considered hazardous waste
and that would be acceptable for most
places to collect
those oilbased paints and solvents
however are hazardous
waste many states have designated
oilbased paints as a universal waste so
Universal wastes are things like your
light bulbs with Mercury in them anti-
freezed um other Mercury containing
devices aerosol cans so these are things
that are technically hazardous waste but
because they're designated as universal
waste the standards to manage them are a
little less strict because most of the
time they're being recycled um and
they're just ubiquitous and it would be
hard to regulate them for everybody that
has them so that's the the thought
behind designating things as universal
waste so we had suggested is rather than
make every Ace Hardware Store become a
generator of hazardous waste because
they took a gallon of of oilbased paint
if we designate that paint as universal
waste then they can take it and not be a
generator of hazardous waste and then
it's still collected and managed the
same way it would be if it was hazardous
waste because it's being picked up by
paint care and being properly disposed
of or recycled if it can be so there's
any questions about
that so in that process when they making
the transfer if there's a spill you want
the state to wave out liability
that's the way this reads right so that
the facility that collects it as long
the way the bill reads as long as
they're doing everything properly if
there's an incidental spill it doesn't
relieve them of having to clean it up it
just relieves them of the liability is
my
understanding so we want to wave our pen
hazardous becomes non-hazardous and we
to wave liability so I mean they clean
clean up their
mess okay okay thank
you
so that convinces me that yes we should
pass
something but it hasn't convinced me
to make this fee
transparent how do we make this fee
transparent how do we make it so we
don't need to worry about what the fee
is or c modifying the fee I want to be
free to let the paint manufacturers
charge whatever they
want given that they're the ones who are
Contracting this uh
codings people
away so it's interesting because um this
is actually the only
legislation um that I worked on that has
a few mentioned in the bill so by like
with dollars and cents on it well I
no sorry there there's a just you can
just stay here for the record my name
dou
SE okay uh my name is Karen Eble May ma
district 7 I'm the prime sponsor of the
bill uh when we went or when they went
through the process of developing a bill
last year there seemed to be interest in
having the fee in there I think from I
don't want to speak for pain care but if
it's your preference not to have the fee
in there I don't think anybody would
object I certainly wouldn't object to it
deleted but I think um representative h
I think that the object the objection I
think the original objection was the
part about
the the retailer disclosing the fee to
the End customer that that got our
attention yes right you know in state
that does not have general sales tax
there that got our attention right and
and so it's interesting because again we
work in different states and different
states have different preferences some
require you to put it on there because
of consumer transparency protection laws
Etc and other states they just have
different opinions so this is just
something I feel like an easily
addressable thing to to accommodate the
needs of a state that has a different
perspective than than Oregon or
something like that um there is language
here that allows folks to incorporate
the fee into the receipt that language
doesn't necessarily need to be there um
if we were to you know write the bill
from zero we might not include it others
have suggested it for transparency
reasons um but the basic the part about
the to the the point about the existing
function of the beer tax where
manufacturer passes to distributor
passes to retailer that is kind of how
these things work well is that they the
fee is passed down correctly from one to
the other and then in terms of when it
the customer buys it it's fully loaded
into the cost and you're right the
customer does not necessarily need to
know about that some states they prefer
they do and if this State prefers not
doesn't have to be there's no nothing
about the functioning of the program
that is contingent on that is what I
should say okay so how much how much am
fee sorry let me
move because it just seems like all this
is all
just again one one more comment the way
it was presented to us the woman that
presented I don't I don't remember her
name um I
think yeah I understood it to be like
the liquor bill but I think the she
understood that we wanted to see that
fee that be transparent we don't but but
she presented it as if it
was that was just something some added
information that was quite frankly not
needed well um I was I was just going to
say as Jeremy um mentioned different
states have interests in different ways
and they also had gone through the
process of this bill last year I think
there's not a problem with removing the
fee specification similarly there's not
a issue with deleting the language that
gives retailers the option of disclosing
the fee um
I mean I think there's language in here
about an auditor I mean at some point
people are really interested in making
sure that what's being collected is
correct um I mean I think we can
certainly talk about all of those things
to um to make this work okay let's do it
I got my pen all right well I mean we'd
have to run it by so the woman who was
here before was Heidi mlli she's at the
American codings
Association um his his boss I think
there is some sensitivity honestly to
the antitrust laws because um you know
if you're sort of setting a fee there's
some concern that's why we don't want
anything about it but they still are
going to be charging okay we can talk
about that and we've got to run it up
the rail to the to the ACA but um do you
have a copying okay all right
so I'm I don't want to just go let's
just go through it and see the things
that you're concerned about Mr chair if
I had my word process or I just every
time it says fee just say
delete I'm right now I'm starting at
page two I don't even know I guess I
have to read the whole
bill and see anywhere is any
mention of this
fee 16
says that's where it starts
line 16 describe the funding
mechanism that okay Jeremy has a comment
so I've worked in a few different
Industries who've
had aspirations to do something like
this but the one thing that holds them
back um is the fact that there are
members of the industry that wish not to
pay this fee that would we call them
Free Riders and they'd much rather just
you know know say no thank you and um
the paint industry is you know 95% of
the paint industry are a members but
there are 5% that are not and um they're
on board with this program like this
program exists in 13 states it's very
successful it's a paragon of success
however without like
section um on page two section one and
two where the fee is sort of established
in statute manufacturers can tell us to
sand and that is what stops any industry
from just doing this if they so choose
so I worked in other Industries where
one company really wanted to do it
another company didn't and the whole
thing scuttled so this language
compelling it is part and parcel of
making sure there are no Free Riders and
that everybody pays in within the
industry and that's the main reason for
this maybe we can come up with different
language
right that provides for a cost additive
but we're
not talking about a fe person we we do
use the phrase funding mechanism we can
massage that but the phrase there is a
fun you see when you put it in our
statutes then it looks like a sales
tax okay it looks like a tax all
right so all I'm saying to you is we
think this is great we're glad that the
paint manufacturers want to do this and
we think it's very POS that the best you
can do maybe is uh uh when you sell
paint you put a something on there some
stand that that you they're
participating in this program and those
freeloaders won't be able to add that on
their cans of
paints yeah you know that that you're
doing this because you are doing a
service you're you're providing a
service uh it's it's a nominal cost and
most of the time like when companies are
giving away giving away something they
say we give certain percentage of our
profits to a nonprofit do like that they
use it as a marketing okay so in my mind
you're doing this as a marketing and so
therefore um you know the terms of the
uh the retailer or anybody like say
we're we're selling the product that
that has is participating in that
takeback program and people are
certainly going to be aware about it
because they're going to see that
display or wherever people leave the
take back paints and the sign's going to
say these are provided by and you could
put the company names that are up there
and so that the consumers know that
you're the good guys who are
participating in the program and yes I
understand there's always freeloaders um
uh you know this committee get we get uh
lots of bills dealing with people who
don't pay their bills like ambulance
balance balance billing bills okay so we
all know about the fact that sometimes
not everybody is a participant but we
just think it's great that you guys are
doing this uh we're giving you clearly
something that's a little squeamish for
us that we're giving you a waiver on
liability to do this to pull this trick
off so that um we're at that extents
where we want to draw the line um I
personally the way I see as business as
the cost of managing those those paints
and how you fit efficiently I don't like
the idea when there's a number when they
put put numbers because when I see
numbers in the bill that means there's a
potential that needs to change it oh I I
totally agree with you on that if you
guys are comfortable with not h i mean
especially uh removing that uh online 26
there that whole
I'm starting at
at I think there we need to come up with
a different uh concept for the idea but
I think we just straight up can delete
section three
entirely um okay there is a part of me
and I hate to say this but uh if I were
to be so Draconian about this that I
would might line in and say a sentence
that the state you know that that
there's no obligation Financial oblig
I was going to I I prefer to just leave
that issue mute and not put it into the
bill but to make it clear because um you
know we have a lot of very conservative
people in the house here on the house
floor and to have the house Commerce
passing this bill um I think they would
really feel very reassured if I had a
sentence in there and said that there
would be no
obligation paid by the consumer but I
just leave it you leave it just get it
out of the bill and and having at the
end of the day this is a wonderful
program that the wholesale that the
manufacturers of paints are going to
provide to the state of New
Hampshire I agree I think I think the
part the last part what you said about
making sure that the public receives
this service um without having um sort
of their their knowledge or having been
thrown in their face or anything like
that reminded reminded Etc that that is
totally achievable again the language
you see here is just in response to what
we've heard from other people who wanted
this in their state and wanted people to
know about it disclosure yada yada but
yeah that part of it is again you've
raised some very interesting things for
me to think about in terms of is it
really necessary if it's the will of the
people that it's not necessary and of
course if it doesn't run 95% of you are
all in compliance and doesn't run a f
I'm talking specifically about the feet
to the consumer that the consumer sees
right on a receipt or anything like that
but in terms of the industry imposing it
upon itself you're not imposing upon
yourself you're all taking this is so we
have this is a semantics conversation
sure okay so what I'm saying is charge a
c is that you you the wholesaler set it
in your price and one of the things that
you do and help when you SE sell the
paint to the retailer when you're
Distributing it you're a distributor and
I I and I bet you guys have Distributors
okay okay and I'm sure what the
distributor is going to say to Ace
Hardware
or Walmart whatever they're going to say
is that um part of this fee is that
we're going to set up at your retail
location this display that's going to
take the paints back and we're going to
bring a truck around once a week or once
a month or whatever it's going to remove
all that all that part is voluntary okay
it's all voluntary so in that sense
that's operated
through this entity that you're doing so
that's what I'm saying there's no
particular need for the consumers to
know other than that how wonderful it is
that the paint they're about to buy has
is participating in this Pro take act
program the part about the consumer
knowing you'll get no disagreement we'll
we'll still put a little brochures up
for them to understand what good it's
doing etc etc but um yeah point taken
about the consumers um not needing to
necessarily be fully so one thing I was
just going to mention this does have an
FN and the and the second committee is
finance um there really isn't a fiscal
effect on this um so maybe uh the chair
would be interested in waving it so it
can just go its merry way I will
absolutely if you take out all this
language that's offending I will
absolutely speak to the chairman and
tell them that they can wave the bill
through um okay well let us take it back
to the assuming that that Dees doesn't
have any
other
cost well I mean you are a Marvel to me
you really are well I think um I after
prasing this yeah I know I I did I just
want to say that um it's as I explained
during the hearing I really under the
circumstances with our Revenue I wanted
to make sure that it was Revenue neutral
for the agency and I was thankful that
pain care um did that I just just for
the heck of it I want to give you a
statistic that I just learned um since
they started this program Pain Care has
collected 75 million gallons of paint
and he said that the uh per
gallon it's 10 to 11 pounds per gallon
of avoided landfill in our in our
neighboring states of Vermont and Maine
where this program has been in place for
about a decade um we've collected almost
two million gallons in those two states
um yeah that's 20 million pounds um you
know 10,000 tons of material that's not
in a landfill uh as a result of this
program uh and that doesn't even include
the cans that's just the cans right
right the cans are also in that total so
that's metal that is metal that is metal
that is metal that is being reclaimed
and recycled not in a landfill not
taking up space I think that's the one
of the key things is that all that
material is both bulky messy potentially
you know leech Etc but it's just not the
if none of that is necessarily um
relevant it's not taking up space it's
being diverted and um 80% of that paint
That's collected is becoming a new
product and putting back into Commerce
so lot upsides there um but certainly in
a state with some landfill challenges
that I think is potentially relevant I
think people care so Mr chair um why
don't we try to come up with some
language um are is it your idea that you
would schedule another work session or
go
straight we will we would I would like
to have Amendment for next
week okay like Tuesday is uh well
Tuesday Tuesday would we would be stuck
in this room uh Wednesday but I I I have
13 uh early bills that yes I'll have
make sure they're all had their final
subcommittee because we don't do
anything you know in the full committee
because that would take too much time
we' like to have it all all the ducks in
a row and we would exec this on the
5th okay okay but yes we'd like to have
if you can have it to I mean if if the
world comes to an end then it would be
pushed to the fourth but we would much
prefer to have you get get us something
next week and and get it to me sooner we
get it to will be in touch with you to
at least talk before we walk in here
with an amendment I want please don't do
because I got to have the amendment
that Revenue why how can it be Revenue
Neal because the state of New Hampshire
you know we don't have any other than we
got to make sure that we haven't done
anything the dees has to follow so yeah
where is this language in here now that
there's to be just just look at the
fiscal note at the end if I look at um
M72 implementated program shall be
implemented with they approved by the
department the department makes and the
date of implementation so I all I saw
was that they have to approve whatever
right the program to approve the plan
there's probably gonna there will be
there'll be rule making stop me if I'm
wrong there'll be there'll be some rule
making so that's the runup to the they
have to approve the plan they have to do
the rule making that's the run up to the
program where was the auditing part oh
four that's just the the money flow
cover where where where page two
line 20 oh 20 I'm sorry n
29 yes that I I want all that gone
anyways all right well we'll have to
we'll have to work on all of that what
was the purpose of the auditor well to
make sure nobody's stealing money yeah
but it's not my money it's your money
who cares it's the it's the
manufacturer's money so we don't I mean
yeah so that I'm assuming that's all
gone well we let's work on it a little
bit okay and we'll figure not work too
much all right no we got to say
something about a cost somewhere we
don't this is okay so the other thing
she asked about Revenue if you want WR
something cost I going to say the state
of New Hampshire has nothing to do with
other than indemnify buying the product
well yeah but they have to approve the
plan
why why do we need to approve it why
don't we we're just trusting that you're
going to do a good job of
it you know and if you're not then the
department you know will say oh my God
you're REM making a mess or you're doing
something wrong they would they would
get to you on this right so how does the
Environmental Services Agency engage
with these programs in other states
um basically the law sets out um a
requirement for a general notion of a
plan to describe the operation of the
program um there's usually a list of
sort of things to discuss in that in
that plan it's in the law here it's in
the sorry in the bill here where it
describes you know basically how much is
this program going to um provide to the
state in terms of locations will it be
convenient will it just provide services
in one city or one to Town Etc just kind
of list kind of describing how the
program is actually going to function um
and then it further describes what
products will be collected through the
program um just again just the overall
scope of what the program will Encompass
what it's going to look like and then um
let's see how the program will be um
managing the material we'll just be
collecting it and sending it off to
someplace unknown or will it be doing
what will be it be doing with it like
your rules and procedures of handling or
something yeah I what contractors will
be used are they reputable you list the
contractors okay I mean you want to make
sure the stuff is being handled
correctly I mean I'm sorry I didn't
quite understand Jonathan just said
something to me and I didn't quite
understand what he said Jonathan milans
with Demmer PR you got to pull it closer
yeah Jonathan malanson with Demmer prol
and Thomas uh you know I think one of
the benefits of having an oversight
agency
manage this program is it also make sure
that whatever contractors are hired you
know they're doing this under their
rules and regulations that they need to
follow to manage these very difficult
materials um to to avoid to
representative Cole's point you know
avoid any type of spills or mishaps in
the transportation of these products oo
now we're running the John Hunt's rule
of licensure would you be apply do we
license people who are going to be
picking this stuff up do we have any
regulation I'm not looking at you now
I'm looking at I'm looking at my state
you're all done we all you're all set
thank you very much you're all set
you're
good
am you want to stay there I mean I don't
know you we're all set we're all set
with you
CLA to the extent that um a party that's
picking up hazardous waste yes is doing
so they're required to be a licensed
hazardous waste trans supporter that's
true now and you already have that lure
we already have that system already in
place absolutely so when we hold a hous
household head space collection day in
municipality yeah they hire a contractor
who is a LIC transporter that's right
okay but if we're changing the
designation from hazardous to Universal
then they don't need those licenses uh I
think that the for the pickup the the
the the folks who are the whole purpose
of that Universal waste designation is
so that the generators don't end up
absorbing a whole host of administrative
and specific requirements that apply so
if a manufacturing facility generates
hazardous waste in any you know
significant amount they usually end up
having to have an an individual employee
or several employees that administer
that make sure they're complying with
the law and and managing their hazardous
waste properly in the case of uh
Universal waste so reason the whole
concept of universal waste was developed
is there are certain waste that we all
generate routin rely in our homes but
they do have hazards associated with
them that could be cans of aerosol paint
oilbased paint any number of other
household products that we have it's not
practical to say to a homeowner because
you generate that waste we want you to
comply with all these requirements that
apply to a manufacturing facility so the
concept of universal waste was developed
to be more practical about it and in the
CA in the case that's being applied here
with paint uh care a paint stewardship
program um essentially we're saying to
that Ace Hardware operator who's just
going to have a cardboard Gaylord box
there where paint cans are going to be
stored as long as he's responsible about
that he's not you know uh storing it
next to a a furnace or something you
know you're creating some kind of a
hazard long as he observes basic
principles of safe storage he's not
going to be subject he's not going to be
treated like he's a manufacturer that
generates a lot of hazardous waste he
can just comply with basic requirements
of safety and then but then when that g
when that transporter comes in to pick
up those wastes they're typically going
to be a licensed Haz waste transporter
because they're consolidating all that
they're may be making a pickup at 10 Ace
Hardwares that day and they're going to
have I don't know 8,000 pounds of you
know some of which is going to be uh
oilbased paints or or or other paint
products that could pose a flammability
Hazard we want those folks to be as we
always do now we already do now we want
those to be uh you know trained trained
and and and properly licensed to do that
safely over the road and do you think
the state should wave the liability yeah
I I I think this is something that you
know we we've
been a paint bill of some sort has been
introduced in a number of sessions so
we've been having this conversation for
more in fits and starts for more than 10
years now that was something that you
know we're Regulators that makes us a
little uncomfortable when someone starts
talking about that but what we realize
is that if you don't provide that um
liability protection the for good reason
the Hazardous Waste laws of the state
are are similar to the federal Superfund
laws and similar to other states they
have they impos strict liability on a
generator or an operator of a site so
what that means is is if you owner op
you own a site even if you didn't cause
the problem if all of a sudden there's
soil or groundwater contamination you're
responsible for that and you can even be
responsible if somebody else did it um
so it's a very strict
liability uh Paradigm in state law and
that's appropriate and necessary because
we have some hazardous way sites that
post some very serious concerns that
would otherwise have no other party to
take care of them but the idea of
telling the owner of your local Corner
Ace Hardware that if he spills a drop of
paint there because he's participating
in the paint Care Program all that
strict liability is going to apply to
him that's a huge disincentive and we
have nobody particip ating in the
program and it would be unnecessary it
would be tanking what could be a really
good safety program for no particular
good reason so that's why over time we
we got comfortable with this language
and we think it's the right thing to do
would you be amable to having it only be
licensed hazardous people that handle
the moving of it and put that in the
bill um yeah I mean I think I have to
talk with some of my staff but uh I
think that's the current the way the
current law would work and I wouldn't I
wouldn't object to that I mean I think
having a a a a a licensed hazardous
waste transporter handling it makes
sense yeah it is rules established by
the
department Keith thank you thank you Mr
chair um just question about the fiscal
note it's uh 50,000 a year approximately
out of the general fund so how it any
oversight that you have to do for this
program how is it funded out the general
fund does it come from the
manufacturer's fees my understanding is
that as the bill is currently
constructed any cost that the state
incurs to administer the program whether
that's reviewing the initial plan
conducting rul making or conducting you
know compliance monitoring further out
is to be reimbursed to the agency by The
Pain Care Program that's the way that's
what we really insisted on is that if
that if the bill like this were going to
be passed State's costs well there may
be some upfront cost that you know we
can't know what we incur until we incur
it but we would be able to and we have a
a well defined and um established cost
recovery program where we we're able to
generate keep track of our time
including overhead and including you
know benefits and all the fully loaded
costs and then sending out invoices on a
quarterly or monthly basis to those just
so I understand the so that bill that
you're talking about would go out to
this pain care program that's correct
that's funded through if we're going to
amend the bill it's funded through
voluntary means by participating
manufacturers yeah I confess I'm not
100% clear how the bill is going to be
amended so I I don't want to I'm not I'm
not sure I'm qualified to comment on
that but as I understand the
conversation that's just taken place uh
paint care would administer the program
through its its member paint
manufacturers of which there are many
and presumably they would agree on
some additional cost on each gallon of
paint to help defay their costs of
administering the program including the
cost they need to reimburse to us so
just one last follow
I just looked up a can a can of paint is
like 60 a gallon of paint is like $60
pretty expensive yes so we're talking
about potentially a 5% fee added to an
already very expensive product if that
um $3 of if if that's what it is I mean
I if a gallon is $1.75 then that's on
the odor of I don't know what does that
work out
I see so I think it's less than 1% what
less thank
you and it's a free market because the
paint manufacturer might decide not to
join the
program um I do see on the
page four we have the annual report and
administrative fees language that's got
massage here it is we're we're trying to
streamline government
remember streamlining government I mean
what's the report what would you tell us
how much paint goes in or paint go out
how much dollars do we need that
information I
don't I mean I unless you can unless the
department can make a rational reason
why we need
that reporting information but you know
as far as we're
concerned um you know we we don't need
that the liability disclosure is a
separate section that that you got to
keep but it it was the annual report
that you know you know no it we're we
want to keep this we want to keep this
lean and mean you know we want this to
be cost efficient for the companies to
provide this product right well I I I
think that you know a lot of the
provisions that have been discussed here
in the hearing I think are in there
because you know we come before the
legislation a lot we we work on a lot of
bills we I think what we were everyone
who was working on this the whole team
were trying to craft a bill that would
address the concerns that we often hear
from the legislature and one of those is
oversight and making sure if there is I
mean however it might be done even if
it's totally voluntary to the extent
that there's going to be an additional
price added to paint someone's going to
be concerned about that a paint
contractor who buys 10,000 gallons of
paint a year is going to notice it right
and they're going to say is that a fair
rep price and you know for example if if
uh if and I don't think they would do
this but if the paint manufacturers
added $7 per gallon to the price
someone's going to notice that and I
think the provisions in the bill as they
are right now are designed to make sure
there's an oversight of that to say well
wait a minute it only cost you 75 cents
a gallon to administer the program but
you're trying to charge your customer $7
so what's going on here and I think that
was the idea of the annual report that's
the idea of monitoring the fee I mean
typically when we come before this
legislature if there's any talk about a
fee the legislature wants the ability to
set that fee and control it they don't
want to they don't even give that to us
in Ru making we understand that um they
typically want the legislature tends to
want to have that Authority and so I'm
I'm I'm having a little trouble
following the conversation that just
happened because it it's different than
my usual experience before the
legislature but that's so Mike you have
to admit that coming in front of this
committee has been a little bit
different than I always look forward to
it but this is only your second time
come
on and I'm sure you're shocked and Amaze
what we did with the p and and in terms
of how how we're doing with this is is
that that um we run on the on the theory
that the marketplace will take care of
itself and so therefore that if the
paint in New Hampshire is more expensive
than in Maine New Hampshire Vermont or
somewhere nearby but I think all three
of those states are already in the
program so if we suddenly became more
expensive to them then yeah they you
might have a question but then they'll
just go bu the paint there okay but in
terms of how if you monitoring that is
supposed to keep them honest about what
they're charging for the paint um I
would think the the the
retailer is going to be the one who's
most conscious because the retailer if
they suddenly realize their customers
are all going are going out of state or
going somewhere else to buy it you know
they're going to say is hey you know you
guys are ripping me off on the wholesale
price so um yeah I I would want you to
really look at that that reporting
requirements and see how much of that
really you need to have if to try to get
it so there's no f note on this bill
right understood see how you can get
there that would be really great okay
enough anybody any
other input from the committee
members thank you very much thank you
tomorrow
yeah
e